[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver sur Public Sénat pour
ceux sixième jour d'examen de la réforme
des retraites toutes les rédactions de
Public Sénat se mobilisent pour vous
faire vivre ces discussions dans
l'hémicycle ces discussions qui seront
suivies notamment aujourd'hui par Steve
Jourdain qui nous accompagne pour suivre
et pour analyser tout l'examen de ce
texte dans l'hémicycle du Sénat bonjour
Steve bonjour Tom alors en ce 7 mars
tous les regards sont bien sûr focalisés
sur cette journée de mobilisation alors
que l'Inter sadicale a appelé à un
mouvement de grève massif et inédit pour
mettre la France à l'arrêt les sénateurs
aussi ont les yeux braqués sur les
manifestations et notamment le cortège
parisien avec 700 000 manifestants selon
la CGT c'est cortège qui passe à
quelques rues du Palais du Luxembourg et
c'est notamment la gauche de l'hémicycle
qui était très intéressé par l'état de
ce cortège car ces sénateurs ne veulent
pas débattre de l'article principal de
la réforme l'article 7 sur le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans qu'après la fin des
manifestations et du coup Steve le débat
prend son temps oui dessinateurs de
gauche qui ont d'ailleurs passé une tête
en quelque sorte au cortège parisien qui
vous l'avez dit Tam sont passés mais à
quelques dizaines du Mai du jardin du
Luxembourg du Palais du Luxembourg la
question qu'on va de désormais se poser
c'est est-ce que le souffle de cette
manifestation et bien va se répercuter
ici dans l'hémicycle du Sénat réponse
d'ici une petite heure maintenant quand
on va examiner l'article 7 alors à quoi
faut-il s'attendre cet après-midi ce
soir et jusque tard dans la nuit et bien
à une gauche très offensive évidemment
il y a une droite qui va en quelque
sorte essayer et bien de jouer la montre
car elle espère et bien voter le plus
rapidement possible cet article 7 de la
réforme des retraites article 7 dont on
va beaucoup parler aujourd'hui sur
Public Sénat l'article 7 qui est en
quelque sorte et bien le cœur du
réacteur le cœur du débat autour de
cette réforme des retraites qui prévoit
le progressif du départ du départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans ce qu'il faut
signal à l'état mais bien c'est que ce
sera la première fois aujourd'hui que
des élus de la République vont débattre
de ce recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite puisque on le rappelle à
l'Assemblée nationale et députés
n'étaient pas parvenu jusqu'à cette
article 7 ce fameux article 7 de la
réforme des retraites merci merci
beaucoup Steve pour toutes ces
explications vous retrouve tout au long
de cette émission et oui depuis le début
de l'examen de ce texte la gauche et
dans une stratégie d'obstruction claire
frontale même si elle est bien plus
calme bien plus posée qu'à l'Assemblée
on entend beaucoup moins la droite qui
ne veut pas faire perdre de temps dans
les débats mais qui adopte les articles
les uns après les autres l'index seniors
le CDI le Seigneur l'ouverture vers une
part de capitalisation collective dans
notre système par répartition néanmoins
la droite sagace de la lenteur des
débats écoutez ce matin le président du
groupe LR au Sénat Bruno Retailleau pas
question qu'on se laisse prendre en
otage par une volonté d'obstruction de
nos oppositions qui est des avis
favorables défavorables qu'on veuille
voter contre c'est pas mon cas mais je
comprends parfaitement et ils sont dans
le rôle de protester ils sont dans leur
rôle de s'opposer on est aussi dans
notre rôle vis-à-vis des Français de
vous voir aller au bout du texte parce
que je le dis aussi à la gauche si vous
voulez qu'on ne voit que l'article 7 ça
signifie que l'article 8 sur les
travailleurs handicapés sur les
Invalides c'est important ça pour les
Français l'article 9 l'usure
professionnelle ceux qui ont durement
peiné pendant toute leur carrière alors
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne doit pas
discuter et je suis à présent avec
Patrick canaire le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat bonjour
Patrick canin votre réaction assez
propos de Bruno Retailleau qui dit il
n'a pas question que la gauche prenne le
débat en otage est-ce que c'est ce que
vous faites aujourd'hui
nous fais votre travail de parlementaire
nous expliquons avec pédagogie
détermination ténacité ce que nous nous
voulons pas et cette réforme n'en
voulant pas et nous avons même proposé
hier toute une série d'amendements pour
dire que cette réforme pouvait se
financer autrement que par le
l'augmentation de l'âge légal et tous
ces amendements ont été refusés par les
amis politiques de Monsieur rotailleau
donc je pense que la première
obstruction c'est de refuser que une
autre voie est possible et elle est
portée par la droite sanatoriale vous
dites que c'est le truc de la droite qui
refuse d'ailleurs de prendre par
la droite extrêmement silencieux je le
regrette parce que ça mériterait les
débats alors bien sûr la droite est
aussi bloquée par le fameux article 47 1
de la Constitution qui limite le temps
de débat parce que c'est une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
bien dans ces cas-là il pourrait être
avec nous pour dire au gouvernement on
ne veut pas de cette méthode On refuse
votre texte renvoyez-le en commission
renvoyez-le au gouvernement et nous
aurons un meilleur texte à défendre et à
présenter aux Français alors ça va être
votre stratégie sur cette ce fameux
article 7 est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
débatte et bien cette nuit à un moment
où ça sera très difficile pour les
Français et bien d'écouter ce débat ou
dans les prochaines minutes comment ça
va se passer l'article 7 commencera à
être débattu en fin d'après-midi 18h un
petit peu avant un petit peu après nous
nous verrons bien donc nous sommes dans
un délai que je qualifierais de
raisonnable les Français ont manifesté
partout en France vous avez vu dans les
métropoles mais aussi dans beaucoup de
petites villes ça montre une forme de
colère qui est en train de monter et
donc ils vont pouvoir assister en
revenant chez eux et bien à ce débat sur
sur l'article 7 je le souhaite avec
encore une fois cette ce souci de
pédagogique j'évoquais tout à l'heure il
faut que les Français sachent qu'il y a
deux projets de société qui sont en
train de s'affronter ici au Sénat les
Français ils sont opposés à la réforme
mais ils sont aussi fatalistes nous dit
certains sondages je pense que la
réforme sera adoptée malgré tout
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites est-ce que
je vois surtout c'est le cynisme du
gouvernement par rapport à ce qui
apparaître comme contradiction en disant
mais on en veut pas mais le gouvernement
est obstiné le seul problème c'est que
si on passe en force contre les Français
ça laissera des traces et si Monsieur
Macron qui est à l'initiative de toute
cette affaire et bien ne comprends pas
que il devrait écouter les Français il
fait le lit aujourd'hui du populisme et
en particulier de celui de l'extrême
droite Patrick kaner la droite le
gouvernement ont toutes les armes
parlementaires pour faire adopter ce
texte pour accélérer sur ce débat d'ici
dimanche pour le faire voter qu'est-ce
que vous espérez pour que cette réforme
ne soit pas votée ce n'est pas possible
normalement d'un point de vue technique
écoutez nous avons nos amendements il y
a près de 1000 amendements de mémoire
sur le seul article 7 nous prendrons une
parole sur article nous expliquerons nos
voix nos choix
si la droite sénatoriale veut nous
bâillonner veut nous bâillonner ça
serait le cas si j'utilise
l'article 38 le 38 avec un orateur pour
un orateur je ne rentre pas dans les
détails mais elle a les moyens
techniques de limiter le débat et bien
je vais vous dire
que la sincérité du débat parlementaire
ne serait pas allée jusqu'au bout et ce
sera peut-être au Conseil
constitutionnel qui aura le soin de le
dire et de censurer ce texte est-ce que
votre objectif est toujours de ne pas
faire voter la réforme dimanche soir
notre objectif je le répète c'est de
voir tous les articles dans de bonnes
conditions encore une fois c'est de la
responsabilité gouvernementale que
d'avoir limité le temps de débat au
travers de l'utilisation d'une loi de
finances rectificative de sécurité
sociale le premier obstructure le peuple
la première obstructeur permettez-moi
l'expression c'est le gouvernement je le
dis je le répète et si le gong sonne le
12 mars à minuit et bien ni à
l'Assemblée ni au Sénat le texte aura
été adopté comme témoins de penser
complètement inédite inédite mais du
fait de qui encore une fois il fait
d'une forme d'obstination et de
certitude d'un seul homme le président
de la République nous sommes dans un
moment où il y a une sorte de dialogue
entre les parlementaires et les
manifestants on voit voilà la
mobilisation là aujourd'hui la
mobilisation de la gauche dans
l'hémicycle qu'est-ce que vous attendez
et bien aujourd'hui de la terre
syndicale sur les prochains jours un
certain appel à un mouvement qui doit
durer une grève reconductive certains
appels à des blocages certains appellent
à mettre l'économie à genoux notamment
du côté de la CGTS je dis simplement que
l'intention syndical a montré une très
très grande responsabilité une très très
grande unité et surtout
une fusion avec le peuple français qui
ne veut pas de cette réforme elle va
s'exprimer après la journée de ce 7 mars
nous tiendrons compte de cette volonté
exprimée ainsi mais le travail
parlementaire est à part et nous
continuerons notre travail ça ne fait
que commencer et si le gouvernement veut
passer en force et bien il s'opposera
non seulement la gauche politique mais
aussi aux Français dans leur plus grande
majorité est-ce que vous espérez de la
mobilisation dans la rue qu'on puisse
tomber sur un scénario comme 1995 ou
même comme sur le CPE ou par exemple et
bien Philippe Martinez l'a rappelé une
réforme a été adoptée mais finalement
elle n'a pas été appliquée elle n'a
jamais été promulguée parce que Jacques
Chirac qui quand même sentait les choses
avec compris que si le promulgué le CPE
et exactement
promulgame cette réforme du CPE aurait
été une bombe sociale dans le pays donc
il faut Macron comprenne que sa réforme
est mauvaise et qu'elle constitue
potentiellement aussi une bombe sociale
il faut qu'il réfléchisse merci beaucoup
Patrick canard d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et tout de suite et bien on
prend la direction de la séance où les
discours les discussions se poursuivent
et vous nous l'avez dit il y a Patrick
canard et bien on n'est pas si loin de
l'article 7 peut-être d'ici une
demi-heure une heure on l'espère en tout
cas on prend la direction de l'hémicycle
d'avoir validé 44 années de cotisation
soit un an de plus que les salariés non
bénéficiaires de ce dispositif quant aux
mesures transitoire elles sont largement
insuffisantes pour maintenir les plus
âgées dans l'emploi le chômage des
seniors vous n'y apporter aucune réponse
si ce n'est des mesures cosmétiques qui
ne réduiront en rien la précarité des
plus de 55 ans en étendant la longueur
des années à attendre pour partir en
retraite vous étendez en réalité la
traversée du désert pour des milliers de
travailleuses et de travailleurs merci
le 36
oui merci madame la Présidente si vous
le permettez je vais défendre
l'amendement de ma collègue parce que je
pense que elle donne beaucoup du sien et
qu'elle a besoin de prendre un petit peu
de salive pour continuer la suite donc
cet amendement propose de rajouter après
les mots améliorant les dispositifs de
prévention et de réparation de l'usure
professionnelle un élément de vérité qui
est que le
report de l'âge de départ de à la
retraite de deux ans
aggravera les problèmes d'usure
professionnelle
utégard à l'allongement de la durée de
travail de nombreux cotisants au sein
d'emploi pénible
madame gréaume
pardon notre amendement vise à corriger
un contresens il est écrit en effet dans
l'alinéa 10 de l'annexe que les
dispositifs compris dans la loi
amélioreront les dispositifs de
prévention et de réparation de l'usure
professionnelle de qui se moque-t-on le
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
de deux ans va dégrader au contraire de
la prévention et aggraver l'usure
professionnelle comment pourra-t-il en
être autrement non seulement les
solutions envisagées pour les métiers
pénibles comme le compte professionnel
de prévention sont extrêmement limités
de nombreux facteurs de pénibilité ne
sont pas pris en compte par cette
réforme les conditions de travail
exposants au port de charge lourdes aux
vibrations mécaniques ou encore aux
postures pénibles ne permettront
toujours pas à elle seule de partir plus
tôt il y a bien la création pour les
métiers identifiés par les branches
comme les plus exposées aux critères
ergonomiques d'un fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle d'un milliard
milliard d'euros mais quand se font sera
créé et surtout qu'elle en sera son
utilité alors non comme je viens de vous
le dire vous mesures d'amélioreront pas
les dispositifs de prévention et de
réparation de l'usure professionnelle à
les affaibliront comme nous le dénonçons
à travers cette amendement que je vous
demande d'adopter merci merci le 4177
même brûlant merci madame la Présidente
cette annexe expose les effets de la
réforme des retraites en ce qui concerne
la prévention et la réparation de
l'usure professionnelle en termes plutôt
élogieux mais particulièrement faux si
vous vouliez véritablement améliorer les
dispositifs de prévention et de
réparation de l'usure professionnelle
vous commenceriez par réintégrer les
quatre facteurs de pénibilité que vous
avez retiré du compte personnel de
prévention de la pénibilité le c-3p
ancêtre du C2P compte personnel de
prévention aujourd'hui en vigueur quels
sont-ils ces critères manutention de
charge manuelle comme un échafaudeur par
exemple qui travaille sur les
plateformes industrielles de mon
département et qui m'explique porter
plusieurs tonnes par mois ce sont aussi
les postures pénibles comme celle de ces
aides-soignantes par exemple qui doivent
porter ou déplacer des résidences en
EHPAD ce sont les vibrations mécaniques
subies par exemple par ses ouvrières de
l'agroalimentaire qui ont parfois le
sentiment qu'on se soucie plus du sort
des poulets qu'elle transforme que
d'elle-même l'exposition encore aux
agents chimiques dangereux et encore une
fois dans un département comme le mien
qui compte deux grandes plateformes
pétrochimiques on sait particulièrement
ce qu'il en est réintégrer donc ces
critères faute de quoi vous serez
définitivement disqualifié pour dire que
cette réforme prévoit et prend en compte
la pénibilité je vous remercie merci le
3673 même pensé mange
oui merci ma présidente alors là on va
arriver vous savez à ce grand débat il y
a combien de personnes qui vont passer à
1200 euros
40000 puis après 20 000 et puis après
peut-être entre 10000 et 20000 1300
voilà c'est un conseil plutôt monsieur
le ministre vous auriez dû tout
simplement vous cantonnez à la mesure
c'est à dire à dire que un certain
nombre de personnes allaient toucher une
revalorisation allant de 0 à 100 c'est
une de vos MInistres qui avait dit ça et
je trouvais ça intéressant parce que de
0 à 100 sans le vouloir elle a oublié de
dire que pour beaucoup c'était zéro
merci le 4157
madame la Présidente assassy défendue
merci le 4160
le 4162 monsieur
oui merci
une fois encore nous vous présentons un
amendement de précision il y en a jamais
de trop afin d'apporter de la clarté à
nos compatriotes par rapport à ce projet
de loi en effet le minimum contributif
est une protection nécessaire mais il ne
remplit pleinement son rôle de filets de
sécurité financière que pour les
carrières complètes or les retraités
pauvres le sont essentiellement du fait
de carrière incomplète et on pense bien
sûr en premier lieu aux femmes ne pas
préciser que ce dispositif exclurant les
personnes ayant eu une carrière
incomplète serait une forme de mensonge
par omission c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous proposons d'inscrire
noir sur blanc que tous nos compatriotes
ne seront pas protégés par votre réforme
merci alors nous avons 11 amendements
identiques le 62 madame Pantel
merci madame la Présidente
le rapport qui figure un annexe au
projet de loi prévoit notamment une
hausse des taux des cotisations
vieillesse du par les employeurs publics
à la Caisse nationale de retraite des
agents des collectivités territoriales
cette augmentation d'un point de 2024
devrait représenter une dépense
supplémentaire pour les employeurs
territoriaux de quelques 460 millions
d'euros par an
il est à noter que seuls les employeurs
publics sauf l'État lui-même auront à
contribuer financièrement à la réforme
puisque pour les employeurs privés cette
hausse sera compensée par une baisse des
cotisations à nous proposons de
supprimer cette hausse des cotisations
sociales pour les employeurs
territoriaux pour plusieurs raisons
cette hausse du taux de cotisations
préalable des employeurs publics elle
représente une double peine pour les
employeurs publics qui font déjà de voix
qui vont déjà devoir assumer les
conséquences financièrement de
l'allongement de l'âge du départ à
retraite enfin toute variation du taux
de cotisation aurait dû avoir pour
préalable la remise à plat du système de
retraite des agents territoriaux
notamment du fait de la part croissante
d'emploi contractuels dans les
collectivités je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Bonhomme
merci pour la présidente western en
demande concomitama au texte il est
prévu donc dans la trajectoire une
hausse de cotisation vieillesse due par
les employeurs publics à la CNRS
ça m'imprégée de l'opinion que chaque
employeur territoire peut porter sur
l'opportunité de rapport de l'âge de par
la retraite cette hausse immédiate du
taux de cotisation
n'a pas fait l'objet de concertation
après la des employeurs publics
rassemblés au sein de la coordination
des employeurs territoriaux laquelle a
clairement exprimé son opposition à
cette mesure compte tenu notamment des
effets induits par la réforme du fait du
maintien prolongé une activité de leurs
agents le gouvernement s'est engagé par
courrier de la première ministre de
janvier 2023 a compensé intégralement
aux employeurs territoriaux cette hausse
de cotisation sans que le véhicule cette
compensation n'était à ce jour arbitré
il apparaît été confirmé aux
associations membres de cette
coordination lors d'une réunion du 13
février que il continuerait à moyen
terme être prélevé au titre de la
compassion démocratique vers les autres
régimes
dans ces conditions là de cotisation
d'un point de des employeurs affiliés à
la cinéacl ne participera pas à
l'équilibre intrinsèque du régime mais
au maintien de la compensation
démographique vers les hautes vers les
autres régimes de ce fait alors
financement indirect il convient donc de
revenir sur cette hausse de cotisation
ainsi la nécessité de ce prélable est
renforcée par l'intérêt d'examiner la
raison de proposition de la CNA Racl en
faveur de l'élargissement de l'assiette
des agents qui sont affiliés
obligatoirement à cette caisse ou encore
par celui de questionner le seuil
d'affiliation à cette caisse
c'est amendement est soutenu par la
coordination des employés des employeurs
publics territoriaux instances
informelles qui regroupe l'ensemble des
associations nationales de l'îloco merci
alors le 122 par Monsieur Levy et si
vous pouviez parler un petit peu moins
fort sur ma gauche
le président madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues cet amendement a pour objectif
de supprimer la hausse d'un point des
cotisations retraite des employeurs de
la fonction publique territoriale et
hospitalière inscrite dans le texte à
partir de 2024
c'était hausse est une mauvaise surprise
et une mauvaise manière sans
concertation préalable dans la mesure où
le gouvernement s'était engagé à ne pas
toucher au cotisations sociales des
employeurs publics pour les associations
d'élus et notamment l'Association des
maires de France il s'agit d'une
aggravation financière pour les
collectivités puisque leur DGF déjà en
baisse subit avec l'inflation une
ponction de 500 millions d'euros et
voilà qu'on leur annonce une mesure qui
va coûter encore
460 millions d'euros supplémentaires par
an et qui aura évidemment des incidences
sur la capacité d'autofinancement des
communes et intercommunalité sur leurs
investissements et sur leurs projets
heureusement nous allons voter un
amendement des rapporteurs qui engagent
l'État à compenser cette hausse pour
autant les élus locaux pointent un
problème de confiance puisque le
gouvernement fait depuis le début le
contraire de ce qu'il avait dit et
qu'ils sont mis devant le fait accompli
d'ailleurs l'Association des maires de
France m'a encore confirmé ce matin
qu'ils auraient préféré une suppression
de cette hausse plutôt qu'une promesse
de compensation sans détails des
modalités
merci Monsieur Arnaud
est largement défendu au moment où je
parle je souhaite simplement
effectivement que à l'issue de
l'amendement proposé par le rapporteur
les rapporteurs on soit dans la
situation et la certitude et la garantie
qui n'aura pas un jeu de bon taux de
passe-passe entre effectivement la
garantie de la compassion tel que elle
nous est proposé par les deux
rapporteurs et le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
parallèlement une baisse de DGF où je ne
sais quelle subventuge qui fasse au bout
du compte ce soit les collectivités
locales pas de manière directe comme
proposée dans le cadre du projet de loi
actuelle mais de manière indirecte qui
finance une nouvelle fois cette nouvelle
hausse de cotisation à destination des
seuls employeurs publics je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames et messieurs
présidents et rapporteur vous voyez que
c'est amendement mission Luminy c'est
particulièrement important puisqu'il
vient de tous les bancs et de tout et de
tous les territoires alors moi je salue
le fait que la première ministre a dit
qu'elle compenserait cette hausse de
cotisation toutefois on a une situation
quand même un peu alambiquée puisque ce
régime de retraite qui concerne les
employés territoriaux et déficitaires et
va abonder le régime général donc nous
comme vous nous aimons bien la cohérence
et les comptes juste donc il y a un
problème je remercie le rapporteur pour
l'amendement qu'ils vont proposer
surtout messieurs les ministres je pense
qu'il faut réviser
l'assise du système de la scène Racl
puisque aujourd'hui
un contrat sur deux dans la fonction
territoriale et l'objet d'un contrat de
contractuel donc le système qui existait
précédemment ne tient plus donc on a la
moitié des nouveaux embauchés qui ne
cotisent pas à cette quête donc si on
peut mettre de l'ordre la solidité de la
pérennité vous seriez ravi de tout ça et
nous encore plus merci merci Monsieur
Genet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues après
avoir écouté les collègues depuis jeudi
dernier avec autant d'attention que de
patients je suis particulièrement
heureux de pouvoir m'exprimer quelques
secondes madame la Présidente en cette
journée du 7 mars et si j'ai acquis au
moins une conviction à vous écoutant
mais chers collègues c'est que le
pouvoir de conviction semble parfois
passer par la répétition donc vous
m'excuserez de répéter ce qui vient déjà
d'être dit excédé par l'ensemble de mes
collègues et en particulier par la
présidente de la délégation collectivité
territoriale et c'est vrai que pour
mettre échapper quelques heures hier
soir pour aller siéger au conseil
municipal de Digoin sur les orientations
budgétaires je peux vous dire que dans
beaucoup de communes qui préparent leur
budget messieurs les ministres les
conditions de
dans lesquels nous pourrons boucler ces
budgets sont particulièrement
inquiétantes parce que se font toujours
sentir bien sûr l'explosion du coût de
l'énergie et un certain nombre de
mesures sur les ressources humaines avec
le point d'indice augmenter en juillet
dernier et ça va s'appliquer pour 12
mois en 2023 mais également un certain
nombre de mesures catégorielles et donc
cette hausse des cotisations serait
vraiment très malvenu et inquiète
beaucoup nos collègues élus locaux et
donc c'est pourquoi il est bon que vous
puissiez entendre cette opposition qui
s'est manifestée sur l'ensemble de ces
bancs et que vous puissiez prendre des
engagements réels sur le sujet je vous
remercie mais monsieur Tissot
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues au sein de
l'annexe de cet article 6 un rapport
décrit les prévisions de recettes et les
objectifs de dépenses par branche des
régimes obligatoires de base les
prévisions de recettes et de dépenses
des organismes concourant au financement
de ces régimes ainsi que l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
pour les quatre années à venir ainsi
parmi ces trajectoires il est prévu une
hausse des cotisations vieillesse du par
les employeurs publics à la Caisse
nationale de retraite des agents des
collectivités locales la cnrcl à hauteur
d'un point et c'est des et ce des 2024
c'est cette hausse du taux de cotisation
on a fait l'objet d'aucune concertation
préalable auprès des employeurs publics
rassemblés au sein de la coordination
des employeurs territoriaux ceux-ci ont
clairement exprimé leur opposition à
cette mesure dans de nombreuses
communications ces derniers ont rappelé
qu'une approche globale devait être
privilégiée par rapport à une variation
du taux de cotisation décidé
unilatéralement par le gouvernement
avant toute décision trois enjeux
doivent être prises en compte et traités
celui de la compensation démographique
de la CNRACL vers les autres régimes
dont les employés demande la suppression
préalable celui de l'équilibre de global
des régimes ou de retraite auxquels
cotise des agents territoriaux et enfin
celui de la réforme annoncée des
parcours et carrières des agents publics
qui pourraient conduire augmenter
substantiellement l'assiette de
cotisation et si votre gouvernement a
exprimé l'intention d'une compensation
financière intégrale de cette hausse
comme cela est proposé dans l'amendement
21 16 des rapporteurs rien ne garantit
évidemment la pérennité de ses
compensations et les précédents
mécanismes mis en place en particulier
suite en particulier de suite à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation ont
effectivement démontré que la
compensation promise n'était pas
toujours au rendez-vous je vous remercie
merci les 3416 même penser mon
bien en plus de tout ce qui a été dit
sur cet article je voudrais aussi
rappeler que comme d'habitude aucune
concertation préalable des employeurs
publics rassemblés au sein de la
coordination des employeurs territoriaux
a été a été faite par le gouvernement et
puis ensuite donc il n'a plus que
constater que cette mesure est
unanimement
ils sont unanimement opposés à cette
mesure dans un courrier du 25 janvier
donc la première ministre s'est engagée
à compenser intégralement auprès des
employeurs territoriaux cette hausse de
cotisation mais sans toutefois précisé
de quelle manière je voudrais rappeler
que ce sont certes les collectivités
territoriales mais c'est aussi la
fonction publique hospitalière et dans
l'état où elle est ce cette nouvelle
mesure est quand même est quand même mal
venue
d'autres mesures enfin d'autres voies
existent monsieur le ministre il s'agit
de s'attaquer là aussi au vrai causes du
déficit des caisses d'en finir avec les
gènes à répétition de des points
d'indice des fonctionnaires de stopper
le remplacement des fonctionnaires par
des contractuels ma collègue en a parlé
et puis aussi des intérimaires qui ne
cotisent pas à cette caisse les baisses
des effectifs les externalisations
représentent autant de problèmes de
budgétaire que d'atteinte au service
public dont on a pu en outre ces
dernières années constatées les
conséquences délétères
dans les hôpitaux c'est évident avec un
transfert des hôpitaux privés ou par
exemple un transfert de crèches
municipales vers les crèches privées
donc nous ce nous notre groupe soutien
la suppression de la hausse de la hausse
d'un point des cotisations de cette
caisse merci les 4235 même brûlant
merci madame la Présidente ça a été dit
cette augmentation de cotisation des
collectivités à la CNRACL va représenter
460 millions d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires par an pour les
collectivités tout cela sans
concertation et je dirais même en total
des accords avec des associations d'élus
qui sont unanimes pour s'opposer à cela
drôle de manière de retisser la
confiance avec les collectivités je
voudrais réinsister sur l'injustice de
cette mesure parce que si les employeurs
publics les collectivités mais aussi les
hôpitaux ça vient d'être rappelé sont
soumis à cette augmentation de
collectivités les employeurs privés eux
ne le sont pas puisque leur cotisations
à la branche accident du travail maladie
professionnelle va être elle compensée
c'est une injustice flagrante alors on
nous explique qu'il faut équilibrer les
comptes de la cnrsl je ne reviendrai pas
sur ce qui a été dit là encore sur le
fait que le nombre de plus en plus
important de contractuels qui quand il
se passe cette caisse et la principale
raison du déséquilibre de cette caisse
alors moi je veux bien qu'on mise
beaucoup sur les compensations et nous
aurons également un amendement qui si
celui-ci c'est ceci n'était pas adopté
demandera à l'état de compenser mais je
voudrais alerter nos collègues ici
d'abord sur le fait que les élus savent
ce qu'il en est des compensations
souvent promises mais rarement au
rendez-vous et enfin dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
comme dans l'article liminaire du texte
que nous examinons aujourd'hui même il
est stipulé expressément que les
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
doivent diminuer de 0,6
ce que vous avez voté mais chers
collègues vous avez voté la loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
vous avez voté cet article liminaire
donc c'est bien que vous le regrettiez
d'ores et déjà et que vous proposiez de
supprimer cette cotisation mais liée les
actes aux paroles c'est encore mieux et
c'est ce que nous ferons pour notre part
si le 452 madame
la Présidente messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues tout d'abord on peut
effectivement le qualifier comme un
amendement de repris de repli pardon par
rapport aux amendements communs qui
viennent d'être défendus précédemment
vous dire peut-être tout de même
messieurs et mes ministres que je crois
que ça commence à suffire que
systématiquement
il y a une forme d'acharnement je dirais
ainsi qui pèse en permanence sur le
budget de nos collectivités
territoriales dans ce pays
l'employeur que sont les collect
territoriale devient finalement celui
qui est le plus en difficulté on fait un
projet de réforme des retraites on
demande une hausse de cotisation en
l'occurrence ici pour la CNRACL on
revalorise les travail les salaires il
appartiendra au collectivités
territoriales de prendre en charge cette
hausse du point d'indice la situation
énergétique et nous en avons
suffisamment parlé ici fait que
finalement il faut prendre une grande
partie pour nombreux d'entre elles de la
hausse de l'énergie dans leur propre
budget et cela fragilise comme je l'ai
déjà dit finalement le service rendu à
la population alors cependant je ne
voudrais pas qu'il y ait de faux débats
comme certains l'ont laissé
sous-entendre lors de la commission des
affaires sociales bien évidemment nous
avons fait une intervention sur arctique
pour défendre les collectivités
territoriales j'ai défendu un amendement
pour défendre l'hôpital donc bien
évidemment loin de nous la volonté
d'opposer les collectivités
territoriales à l'hôpital public je le
dis apparemment certains s'en sont émus
et donc je demande une modification de
notre amendement pour le rendre conforme
à celui de Madame la rapporteur en
retirant en particulier les
collectivités territoriales même si je
pense que collectivement nous avons une
pensée très forte pour celle-ci merci le
216 de la commission des affaires
sociales même la rapporteur
oui je crois que sur tous les bancs nous
défendons les collectivités locales et
pas que parce qu'il y a tous les
établissements publics que ce soit les
établissements hospitaliers ou autres
mais pour reparler des collectivités je
sais combien vous êtes soucieux les uns
les autres dans cette période compliquée
où l'énergie coûte plus cher ou
l'alimentation coûte plus cher et où
finalement on a aussi ce qui a été
augmenté en termes de points d'indice
pour le personnel l'année dernière on a
tout ça en tête pour les collectivités
et donc ici dans cette chambre haute
effectivement on l'a vu à travers vos
propos il y a une prise directe et donc
c'est au niveau de la commission des
affaires sociales que nous avons voulu
aussi défendre les collectivités et
comme je le disais l'ensemble des
établissements publics c'est donc pour
cette raison que nous avons déposé cet
amendement et celui de Madame assassy
effectivement rectifié l'identique sera
comme je le dirai tout à l'heure j'y
serai favorable pour la commission
le 41508
défendu madame la Présidente cette
annexe pose les bases de l'analyse des
effets de cette réforme comme nous
l'avons déjà dit on ne peut en
conscience proposer cette réforme
injuste sans accorder d'importance à la
santé des travailleurs
or il est évident que cette réforme aura
des impacts sur la santé des Français en
ignorant la pénibilité en maintenant
dans la précarité plus longtemps des
sillons au chômage en grignotant un peu
plus les années de vie en bonne santé de
nos compatriotes cette phrase de la de
la lignée à 10 présente les enjeux du
rapport annexé au PLF RSS nous entendons
qu'elle intègre également la question de
la santé des Français confrontés à
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
selon le ministère de la santé il faut
savoir que 23% des Français souffraient
d'une limitation physique lors de leur
première année de retraite en 2018 les
plus touchés bien sûr sont les ouvriers
mais pas que un tiers des ouvriers et un
quart des employés sont dit en
incapacité lors de la première année de
retraite une étude réalisée publiée en
2021 au titre de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques stipule clairement
que le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite tant augmenté significativement
la fréquence et la durée des arrêts
maladie notamment en raison de l'état de
santé des travailleurs en fin de
carrière
merci le 3675 même pensé mange
monsieur salmon un
c'est la fatigue
donc des chiffres absolument effarants
mais non moins réels sont apparus dans
le débat public à l'occasion de la
réforme des traits des retraites
actuellement c'est un quart des 5% les
plus pauvres qui sont déjà morts à 62
ans et ce chiffre des hommes bien sûr ce
chiffre monte à 1/3 à 64 ans le report
de l'âge va donc aggraver les inégalités
sociales face à la mort aujourd'hui les
plus pauvres passent en moyenne cette
année de moins à la retraite que les
plus aisées la réforme va donc leur
prendre de nouvelles années de vie à la
retraite et creuser encore plus la
différence de vie à la retraite entre
les riches et les pauvres avec la
réforme ce sont donc chaque année les
statistiques sont implacables 9000
personnes supplémentaires qui auront
cotisé toute leur vie mais qui mourront
avant de pouvoir bénéficier de leur
retraite notre amendement vise donc à
mettre en lumière cette réalité dans la
loi
besoin que l'annexe visait à l'article 6
puisse refléter de façon plus juste les
effets réels de la réforme sur la vie
des Françaises et des Français au-delà
des seules considérations budgétaires et
comptables
le 3489 à impensé Monge
même vos gènes
pardon merci madame la Présidente oui
alors cet amendement vise à supprimer
les mots la normalisation progressive de
la situation sanitaire comme si les
perspectives financières de cette loi
allaient normaliser l'état de la
situation sanitaire dans notre pays en
réalité ce que ce que décrit ces
perspectives financières c'est pas du
tout qu'il va y avoir un retour à la
normale de notre situation sanitaire en
France c'est simplement que le
gouvernement a prévu de ne pas faire les
investissements nécessaires dans notre
système de santé pour qu'on puisse avoir
un service public de santé digne de ce
nom et donc dans les faits la situation
de l'hôpital public et de la santé
publique dans notre pays va se dégrader
alors vous pouvez appeler ça
normalisation progressive de la
situation sanitaire nous trouvons que ce
n'est pas vraiment l'expression
idoine et donc nous le retirons
d'accord merci beaucoup alors le 4165
nous interrompons quelques minutes le
débat alors que d'ici quelques dizaines
de minutes on devrait arriver à
l'article névralgique de ce texte
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
car nous sommes avec la présidente du
groupe communiste au Sénat Eliana si
bonjour bonjour Eliane assassy on a
entendu Bruno Retailleau ce matin dire
qu'il était prêt à accélérer les débats
on le sait la droite le gouvernement ont
des armes parlementaires pour pouvoir
accélérer le débat qu'est-ce que vous
leur dites aujourd'hui
je dis qu'il devrait écouter ce qui
s'est exprimé aujourd'hui dans la rue on
a vu une manifestation parisienne moi
j'ai fait les trois précédentes
grandiose aujourd'hui à l'évidence il
s'est passé aussi des choses dans les
petites villes les moyennes villes les
grandes villes de de hors Paris donc je
dis attention attention
la colère est très forte dans le pays
l'exigence du retrait de cette réforme
monte de plus en plus donc il faut
savoir écouter ce qui se dit dans la rue
dans la rue ce sont des gens ce sont des
nos concitoyens et nos concitoyens donc
il faut savoir les entendre
majoritairement les gens ne veulent pas
de cette réforme et des millions
l'expriment encore aujourd'hui dans la
rue mais vous le voyez il y a un
véritable contraste entre ce qui peut se
passer au Sénat ou la droite est
majoritaire et ce que l'on voit dans la
rue puisque les différents points du
texte qui ont précédé ont été adoptés
les uns sur les autres à l'index senior
le CDI ça n'empêche pas ça n'empêche pas
les mobilisation ça n'empêche pas les
mobilisations malgré le vote de mesure
qui sont attentats attentatoires au
droit de nos concitoyens nos concitoyens
il y a des millions de gens aujourd'hui
dans la rue donc ils devraient un petit
peu entendre que malgré ces votes là la
colère est toujours là mais non
seulement elle est la belle s'exprime
encore plus fortement donc vous voyez
c'est leur silence dans l'hémicycle est
assourdissant le silence de la droite et
des centristes états sur 10 ans c'est
quand même incroyable qu'il soit aussi
comment dire éloigner de ce que pense le
peuple aujourd'hui de notre pays sur
cette réforme c'est quand même assez
incroyable parce que après tout ce sont
des élus ils ont des électeurs qu'ils
soient sédataires ou qu'il soit élu élu
locaux donc quand même il devrait
l'entendre ce message j'avoue j'avoue
que je ne les comprends pas et pour
venir à votre première question
moi je dis chiche qu'ils utilisent des
procédures
mais je peux vous dire que en priorité
les amendements
du Sénat a des procédures réglementaires
qu'il a sa disposition non je sais que
le gouvernement a le petit frère du 49-3
aussi à sa disposition c'est tout ça on
dépanaïfs on a exactement en 2010 par
exemple donc on a mis toutes les
hypothèses dans sur la table mais tout
ça ne créera pas des conditions qu'on se
bâillonne
qu'on se bâillonne aujourd'hui non on
continuera à porter nos propositions et
même si des procédures sont déclenchées
on peut défendre nos amendements donc on
défendra nos amendements c'est ça que
votre stratégie sur l'article 7 il y a
presque 80 amendements de suppression
aujourd'hui vous allez vous battre la
pièce
article et nous voulons que cet article
soit soumis au vote des sénatrices et
des sénateurs chaque française et chaque
Français a le droit de savoir ce que son
parlementaire a voté est-ce qu'il est
pour la réforme ou contre la réforme
vous l'avez dit l'article 7 c'est le cas
du réacteur
donc c'est un vote très important donc
nous nous tenons au débat et aux votes
sur cet article 7 vous tenez au vote sur
cet article 7 est-ce que vous tenez au
vote sur l'ensemble du texte dimanche 12
mars sincèrement derrière l'article 7 il
y a des articles encore 13 ans 13 ans
sur les 1200 euros sur la pénibilité
enfin etc donc on va on va aussi faire
ce que nous faisons depuis le début de
l'examen de ce texte c'est-à-dire que
nous allons défendre nos amendements
avec des propositions alternatives ça
prendra le temps que ça prendra y
compris s'il y a recours à des à des
procédures donc si le texte n'est pas
terminé dimanche soir à minuit et ben il
ne sera pas terminé dimanche soir à
minuit ça vous poserait pas de problème
vous le souhaitez moi non ça ne me
posera aucun problème je suis en phase
avec ce que les gens disent dans la rue
justement
dans la rue et bien la manifestation est
importante aujourd'hui
la CGT parle de 700 000 manifestants
dans le cortège parisien bon on n'a pas
encore
les les chiffres d'occurrence ou du
gouvernement euh qu'est-ce que vous
attendez des prochains jours puisque on
entend des appels à la grève aujourd'hui
je ne suis pas une organisation
syndicale donc je laisse le soir aux
organisations syndicales de décider
quels seront les suites des de de cette
mobilité mobilisation pour exiger le
retrait de ce texte donc on verra ils
doivent se réunir me semble-t-il en fin
d'après-midi je me demande même s'ils ne
sont pas déjà et donc on verra ce qu'il
décideront et nous nous prolongerons en
fait les décisions qui seront prises par
par l'intersydical nous n'avons pas à à
nous comment dire à interférer dans
les travaux de
l'intersyndical ils vont se réunir
prendre des décisions et nous nous
allons prolonger d'un point de vue
politique
ce qu'il décideront de faire est-ce que
vous vous reconnaissez dans ceux qui
sont dans une certaine radicalité qui
disent qui sont prêts à mettre la France
à genoux on peut attendre c'est quoi la
réalité
c'est quoi la radicalité c'est quoi la
radicalité vous savez moi il y a des
mots comme ça qui me chiffonnent
obstruction pour parler de Parlement le
radicalité
on est dans d'autres rôles de
parlementaires il y a un texte on y
opposé on fait des propositions
alternatives on n'est pas dans
l'obstruction voilà on est on est ce que
nous sommes une gauche d'opposition et
qui propose voilà c'est pas de
l'obstruction ou alors on rentre chez
nous qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise moi et et et et donc voilà on
en est là et radicalité ça veut dire
quoi radicalité il y a des mots comme ça
qui émergent dans l'espace public qui
font peur aux gens
qui crée de la confusion qui sont
limites anxiogènes mais pourquoi il y a
pas de radicalité regardez toutes les
manifestations ce sont déroulées
tranquillement qu'est-ce qu'on attend
qu'est-ce qu'on attend qui est le feu à
Paris pour que le gouvernement nous dise
voyez c'est les mobilisations les
syndicats ne tiennent rien non tout se
passe bien comme je l'ai dit en séance
vous aviez pas tout va bien se passer
voilà une expression consacrée tout à
fait voilà bien merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir répondu à mes questions alors
qu'on attend allez dans quelques
dizaines de minutes peut-être cet
article 7 qu'on a ne finit pas
d'attendre merci beaucoup Hélène
assassin d'avoir répondu à mes questions
on va tout de suite rejoindre
l'hémicyclin c'est l'art apporte en
général de la commission des affaires
sociales Elisabeth donne ok est en train
de s'exprimer
essayer de répondre
à la demande d'un temps choisi qui soit
mieux qu'un temps qu'un temps partiel et
aussi de répondre à cette pénibilité que
vous évoquez pour certains
je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
effectivement à tout ça et on aura
l'occasion dans un des articles de le
faire puisqu'il y a ce fameux fond
d'usure professionnelle et c'est et
c'est mon collègue qui vous en parlera
comme il y a aussi le front de
prévention qui est très intéressant on a
pu entendre d'ailleurs les deux
personnes qui sont en charge de ce
dossier et donc en tout cas vous avez
effectivement parlé de beaucoup de
sujets intéressants nous proposons en
revanche de donner un avis favorable
madame la Présidente à la nécessaire
actualisation par le gouvernement des
objectifs de dépenses de recettes et de
soldes des régimes obligatoires de base
de la sécurité sociale et en conséquence
le rehaussement de l'ONDAM 2023 et c'est
donc un avis favorable à l'amendement du
Gouvernement 47 22 et pour tous les
autres un avis défavorable
merci beaucoup la vie de gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente en essayant
d'aller aussi vite que possible mais il
y a évidemment beaucoup de sujets qui
ont été abordés et des sujets
d'importance je vais m'arrêter sur le
sujet de la cnr-a.cl donc je sais qu'il
a beaucoup fait parler certains faits
références à la conclusion en cours des
budgets dans les collectivités locales
j'étais moi-même en conseil municipal il
y a quelques semaines dans le conseil
municipal où je siège depuis 10 ans je
fais partie des membres du gouvernement
qui sont aussi élus locaux on avait la
discussion sur le débat d'orientation
budgétaire je siège dans l'opposition
dans ma commune donc j'ai été interpellé
par le maire sur la hausse de
cotisations
cnrcl et donc j'ai eu l'occasion de lui
dire un certain nombre de choses en
primeur du coup mais je vais vous les
dire ici évidemment d'abord la cnr-a-cl
est en déficit de manière importante
à horizon 2030 c'est 8,4 milliards
d'euros de déficit c'est-à-dire 62% du
déficit total de notre système de
retraite pourquoi parce que la cnrracl
connaît de façon plus forte encore que
les autres régimes le déséquilibre
démographique il y avait quatre
cotisants pour un retraité cnr-cl en
1990 c'est aujourd'hui 1,5 cotisants
pour un retraité donc on est en dessous
du ratio démographique tout régime à
partir de là à chaque fois qu'il y a eu
des réformes des retraites des réformes
paramétriques en 2003 en 2010 en 2014
elles ont conduit à résorber une partie
du déficit de la CNRACL le fait de
travailler plus longtemps par définition
a aussi un impact à la baisse sur le
déficit de la CNRACL et elles se sont
toutes accompagnées de hausse de
cotisation CNRS de hausse de cotisation
employeur j'ai entendu notamment sur
certains bancs accusés le gouvernement
d'attaquer les collectivités locales
parce qu'il y aura une augmentation du
taux de cotisation CNRACL je veux
rappeler quand même que sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande
2012-2017 tous les ans il y a eu des
hausse de cotisations cnrcl pour les
employeurs territoriaux de 1,5%
certaines années du même plus de 1,55 %
certaines années il y a une différence
entre les hausse de cette époque et
celle que nous faisons c'est que les
hausses précédentes de cotisation cnrcl
quels étaient portées par des
gouvernements de droite ou de gauche
n'ont jamais été compensés aux
collectivités locales c'est la première
fois qu'un gouvernement s'engage à
compenser une hausse de cotisations
CNRACL aux collectivités locales ça
mérite quand même d'être souligné
puisque avant les cotisations
augmentaient tous les ans sous certains
quinquennat jamais de compensation nous
on pense voilà et donc très concrètement
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
très concrètement qu'est-ce qui va se
passer d'abord le recul de l'âge légal
de départ de deux ans à un impact sur le
déficit de la CNRAC il va réduire le
déficit de la CNRACL d'un milliard deux
à horizon 2030 ensuite on propose une
hausse de cotisation d'un point je
précise quand l'absence de réforme et si
on voulait combler le déficit de la
cnrsl à horizon 2030 uniquement par de
la hausse de cotisation il faudrait
l'augmenter de 12 points 12 points de
hausse de cotisation on fait un point de
hausse de cotisation 700 millions
d'euros et on le compense aux
collectivités locales c'est l'engagement
qu'on a pris j'ai réuni avec mes
collègues Stanislas Guérini et Dominique
Faure les associations d'élus les
employeurs territoriaux on a une longue
réunion avec avec eux de plusieurs
heures je leur ai dit que j'étais ouvert
sur les modalités de compensation et que
je souhaitais les travailler avec eux
il y a plusieurs possibilités soit on
fait un prélèvement sur recettes en PSR
soit on passe par la DGF soit on fait ce
qu'on appelle un swap de taux c'est à
dire un échange de taux avec les
cotisations familles j'ai dit aux
associations des lieux aux employeurs
territoriaux je vous laisse travailler
ces différentes pistes on est prêt à
vous donner des précisions sur les
différents scénarios et on choisira
ensemble la manière dont on compense
cette hausse de cotisation on doit se
revoir dans les prochaines semaines et
donc on avancera avec eux donc tout ça
pour dire que je suis défavorable aux
amendements qui proposent de revenir sur
la hausse de cotisations puisque ça
serait un mauvais coût porté à la
cnr-a-cl dont on a quand même besoin
d'appuré le déficit et la dette que par
ailleurs la hausse de cotisation
s'accompagne d'une compensation par
l'État ce qui est inédit dans notre
histoire et donc que je donne un avis
favorable aux deux amendements assassis
et Doisneau donc le 45 02 recbis et le
21 16 vous noterez que voilà après hier
soir c'est un autre amendement venant
des bancs de la gauche auquel on donne
un avis favorable il y a donc une vraie
ouverture de notre part de notre part
donc voilà mais je m'en vais bientôt
comme le dit Olivier du soft donc pas de
chance
je donne un avis défavorable aux autres
amendements et évidemment un avis
favorable par principe au 47 22 du
gouvernement
merci alors comme nous avons beaucoup
d'amendements pour les demandes
d'explication de vote je vais appeler
les amendements et vous me direz sur
lequel vous vous parlez sauf si c'est
général auquel cas je vous le donne tout
de suite la parole
monsieur Chaumier c'est sur la totalité
c'est à dire c'est juste sur un
amendement madame la prudente sur celui
du gouvernement c'est tout donc ça va
être court puisque sur les autres on va
pas se répéter
le gouvernement donc modifie de 600
millions l'enveloppe de l'hôpital et de
150 millions celle de la ville sur
l'hôpital donc j'en ai parlé ce sont ces
destinés manifestement de ce qu'on
comprend du cours texte qui nous a été
transmis à proroger des mesures
d'horreur valorisation très bien mais ça
ne prend toujours pas en compte
l'inflation le niveau de l'inflation
2023 qui est supérieure à ce qui était
attendu donc c'est un premier problème
sur la ville 150 millions là on avait un
Honda m'a plus de 9 dont on avait pointé
qui portait un carcan qui allait rendre
très compliqué les accords avec les
professionnels de ville et c'est qu'il
devait arriver arriva c'est l'échec des
négociations conventionnelles ça fait
très longtemps qu'on n'a pas vécu cette
situation dans notre pays et il faut pas
chercher beaucoup plus loin
de la cause la cause de cette échec
voilà et puis dernier point moi je me
félicite que le gouvernement donc en
mettant dans un PLFSS rectificatif une
modification de 750 millions de Londres
prend acte que c'est légitime et donc
nous attendons que les années
ultérieures les modifications d'un tel
niveau de l'âme face effectivement
l'objet d'une loi de finances sociales
rectificative qui soit présentée à la
commission des affaires sociales et donc
nous voterons l'amendement du
Gouvernement merci donc même vos gel et
Monsieur Breuillet c'est sur la totalité
aussi même vos gel en premier
merci madame la Présidente c'est pas sur
la totalité c'est sur un amendement mais
je vous donne le numéro c'est le 36 73
de ma collègue Raymonde poncer mon je
voulais juste dire donc c'est
l'amendement qui consiste à préciser
dans l'annexe que le nombre de personnes
en France qui vont être touchées par la
hausse de la retraite à 1200 euros
s'élève entre 10 et 20 000 le
Gouvernement et la commission ont donné
un avis défavorable à cet amendement et
je voudrais dire que pour une fois
plutôt d'accord avec le gouvernement
avec la Commission et je suis désolé
Raymonde mais je pense effectivement
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont un point là
puisque comme dirait l'un il faut avoir
l'humilité de dire qu'il a eu du
flottement
alors je voulais juste me permettre
excusez-moi de vous montrer un petit
graphique ça c'est le nombre de
personnes a priori concernées par les
1200 euros de retraite minimale depuis
le début de la Réforme donc là on est le
10 janvier on a environ 4 et demi
millions de personnes qui croient
qu'elles vont avoir une retraite minimum
à 1200 euros pour tout et tous une fois
que la réforme aura été adoptée je sais
que je
c'est un graphique qui reprend les
données du gouvernement je crois pas que
ce soit sultan si vous les trouvez
insultante ça vous regarde je vous
remercie donc là on est le 10 janvier le
15 février monsieur du stop sur France
Inter nous dit en fait ce sera 40000
personnes de plus chaque année
le 28 février c'est en fait entre 10000
et 20000 donc tu vois Raymond on est ici
mais là comme en fait on n'est plus le
28 février on est le 7 mars on doit être
vers là donc je pense que c'est plutôt
7000 et en fait je ne sais pas à combien
on sera quand on aura fini le vote et
pour cette raison vous me permettrez de
préciser à ma collègue vraiment que je
suis désolée mais je vais m'abstenir sur
cette amendement je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Bruyer
oui on va interrompre quelques instants
les débats on va rejoindre Steve
Jourdain car nous sommes maintenant à
quelques minutes de cet article 7 que
nous n'en finissons pas d'attendre Steve
on finit pas de l'attendre on est
actuellement effectivement sur l'article
6 c'est un article extrêmement technique
puisqu'il parle et bien de la
trajectoire budgétaire de cette réforme
des retraites mais ne zappez pas ne
bougez pas rester sur Public Sénat je
vous promets mais dans quelques instants
une séquence beaucoup plus politique
beaucoup plus binaire en quelque sorte
beaucoup plus clivant puisque les
sénateurs vont devoir répondre à une
question très simple qui est pour qui
est contre le recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite ils vont effectivement vous
l'avez dit à m'examiner l'article 7 de
cette réforme je peux d'ores et déjà
vous faire une petite bande-annonce un
petit teaser de ce qui va se passer on
va voir une gauche remonter à bloc
contre cet article 7 la gauche on
rappelle ici au Sénat est composé de
trois groupes il n'y a pas de nupet il y
a trois groupes les écologistes les
socialistes et les communistes ils ont
déposé plusieurs milliers d'amendements
sur ce seul article
7300 amendements au total et sur ces
1300 amendements et bien il y en a 77
qui sont des amendements dit de
suppression c'est-à-dire des amendements
qui viennent dire niet non au recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite de l'autre
côté de l'hémicycle la droite le groupe
LR devrait être beaucoup plus sage au
moment d'examiner bien cet article 7 il
va falloir voir comment ils vont réagir
aux prises de parole de la gauche est-ce
qu'ils vont défendre pied à pied cette
réforme lancée par Emmanuel Macron c'est
une position pas très simple pour le
groupe LR une position en quelque sorte
d'équilibriste eux qui veulent et bien
se distinguer d'Emmanuel Macron on va
voir comment ils vont réagir beaucoup
avaient annoncé la fin du clivage
droite-gauche il devrait être démenti ce
soir Tam merci merci beaucoup Steve pour
toutes ces explications et en attendant
bien on reprend la direction des débats
dans l'hémicycle là on voit bah c'est
les écologistes qui s'exprimer c'était
Daniel Bruyer puis voilà parce qu'elle
connaît qui reprend la parole la vis
présidente du Sénat qui préside la
séance et c'est Raymond poncer mon chef
de fil des écologistes qui s'exprime à
présent c'était un peu optimiste
effectivement je le conseille quant à
mon collègue Daniel j'avais lui demander
la formule latine pour moi aussi
rappeler au ministre que je lui demande
de retirer les 3 milliards qu'il a mis
indument dans les mesures
d'accompagnement de cette réforme et qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être les mesures étant
de 3 milliards et de six mais c'est pas
pour ça que j'intervenais en plus c'est
pour répondre aussi à ce qui a été dit
sur la caisse des collectivités locales
monsieur le ministre vous dites à terme
en 2030 ça rapportera cette réforme
prise sur les travailleurs Daniel
Brunier vers le dire 1 milliard deux
d'amélioration donc de la caisse j'ai
posé la question aux responsable de
caisse des dépôts de consignation qui
gère séquestre
je lui ai demandé quelle avait été
l'effet du Ségur de la santé
c'est à dire des salaires versés les
primes des augmentations de salaire etc
donc des cotisations sur la caisse il
m'a dit et bien ça a donné un an moi
j'avais 850 millions et je voulais lui
demander si 850 millions étaient exact
il m'a dit effectivement ça a donné un
an de détente à la caisse ça a donné en
fait le même effet que votre réforme
donc plutôt que votre réforme je vous
propose de doubler ce que vous avez fait
pour le Ségur de la santé merci Madame
vermillier
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
intervenir donc concernant cette hausse
de points CNRACL moi j'avais déposé un
amendement concernant cette hausse mais
il se retrouve à l'article additionnel
après l'article 13 je pense que c'est
plus important de d'intervenir à cet
instant cette hausse de points prévoit
de rapporter 600 millions par an
jusqu'en 2028 pour compenser une partie
du déficit CNRACL et puis 700 millions à
partir de 2028 or lacération du fait de
son déséquilibre démographique
elle est malgré tout aujourd'hui
contributrice nette au régime des
compensations démographiques et elle
contribue aujourd'hui à hauteur de 670
millions par an
je pense en termes de méthode qu'il
aurait été plus simple de supprimer la
contribution de la CNRACL à cette
contribution démographique et ne pas
procéder à cette hausse CNRS que Madame
la rapporteur vous proposait un
amendement le gouvernement va compenser
très bien mais si on doit revoir dans un
prochain PLFSS ces contributions nettes
aux compensations démographique on
s'apercevra effectivement qu'il n'est
plus justifié que la CNRACL fasse cette
contribution démographique elle sera
sans doute revue dans l'ensemble des
contributions démographiques le
principal contributeur étant la CNAV
aujourd'hui avec plus de 4 milliards
mais on s'apercevra que cette
contribution n'est plus vraiment due par
la scénaire à ciel le problème c'est que
la hausse du point elle aura eu lieu et
c'est ça va être à mon avis très
compliqué je doute que dans les années
qui viennent on revienne sur cette
hausse de taux donc en termes de
méthodes moi je veux bien que le
gouvernement compense il y a pas de
problème mais ça aurait été plus simple
de se rendre à l'évidence la CNRACL elle
n'a plus lieu de compenser des
compensations démographiques merci
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est une précision on a déjà eu
l'occasion de son entretenir c'est
madame le rapporteur général qui s'est
occupé de cette question là il n'empêche
qu'il y a effectivement des différences
par rapport à la somme des caisses
puisque cette caisse de cnrsl a une
cotisation patronale à hauteur de 34%
déjà c'est quand même important quand le
on sait que le privé aux alentours de
28%, mais le public les caisses de
l'État sont plutôt aux alentours de
74%. donc un jour ou l'autre ça fait les
équilibres dans le dispositif et c'est
pour ça que certains disent derrière que
on cache 30 milliards d'euros qui
alimenteraient le dans les rapports du
corps qui alimenteraient le système de
retraite non c'est selon les
compensations et si on touche à la
compensation démographique qui est
effectivement un sujet d'ajustement en
fonction de la démographie de chacun des
régimes mais il faut toucher à tous les
régimes faut pas toucher qu'à la
scénarcl donc ça mérite une réflexion
approfondie car c'est vrai elle compense
en étant déficitaire parce qu'elle était
sur une progression de son nombre de
cotisants que maintenant elle est au
contraire sur une diminution du nombre
de cotisants c'est une bonne question
mais elle mérite une analyse plus
précise c'est la raison pour laquelle la
rapporteur général n'a pas retenu cette
proposition
merci alors je vais mettre au bois alors
tout d'abord
oui même
la présidente monsieur les ministres
Messieurs les Présidents importants
juste sur l'ensemble des amendements moi
je voudrais saluer l'intelligence et la
finesse du raisonnement de notre
collègue vermillet
il me semble que si t'étais plus simple
de ne pas procéder à des augmentations
ce qui aurait évité des contributions
bref je vous invite messieurs les
ministres à réfléchir à cette bonne
suggestion merci à Madame assassy ses
collègues et aux rapporteur pour
l'amendement mais Monsieur le Ministre y
impôt auquel vous n'avez pas répondu je
pense qu'on a un problème de déficit
démographique puisque aujourd'hui je
l'ai dit dans mon amendement on a la
moitié des personnels des collectivités
qui sont embauchées comme contractuel
donc qui ne cotise pas alors même qu'on
a une masse de gens à partir donc
monsieur le ministre j'ai bientôt nous
quitter mais moi je vous propose un
devoir du soir la question de Madame
vermillier et puis celle de
l'élargissement de la base du système de
CNRACL et je retire mon amendement
madame
oui monsieur le ministre
notre cours parce qu'effectivement
j'avais pas répondu à ce point merci
d'avoir retiré votre amendement ça fait
partie des discussions qu'on a eu avec
les employeurs territoriaux et qu'on a
par ailleurs avec la CNR Racl on a parlé
de une remise à plat du système parce
que comme vous l'avez dit vous avez de
plus en plus de contractuels qui par
définition de cotise pas à la cnr-a-cl
ce qui contribue au déséquilibre
démographique donc il y a une remise à
plat à faire qui va prendre un peu de
temps quand même c'est un chantier
d'ampleur mais on s'est engagé
évidemment à travailler sur ce point
avec les employeurs territoriaux et
évidemment aussi avec la représentation
nationale
merci alors donc je mets aux voix
l'amendement de 1900 de Madame Lubin
avis défavorable la Commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
pour l'amendement
3476 je suis saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe écologiste
donc je vous rappelle la ville de la
commission est défavorable du
gouvernement défavorable il va être
procédé au cru d'un public dans les
conditions fixées par la il est retiré
vous retirez le scrutin public vous
retirez l'amendement
le scrutin public
même pour c'est bon oui
ce comptable veut dire que nous retirons
toutes les demandes
de scrutin public relative à l'article 6
d'accord merci beaucoup c'est plus clair
merci alors donc je mets aux voix donc
l'amendement 346
donc du groupe écologiste
avis défavorable donc du gouvernement et
de la commission qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté un moment de 1900 et de Madame
Lubin même avis ce qu'on considère même
vote oui
la maman 3641 un pont c'est Monge même
avis même vote
le 3676 le 3678 le 3473 le
2897 de Madame Lubin mais ma vie même
vote le 2902 également
4131 madame assassin le 3667 madame
Poncet Monge m'arrêter on nous avait
annoncé qu'il allait y avoir une
accélération dans les débats on
l'attendait constater déjà qu'il y a un
premier signe c'est que le groupe
écologiste vient de renoncer à toutes
ces demandes de scrutin public sur cet
article 6 et donc vous le voyez ce sont
des votes amanovés et qui se font de
façon à beaucoup plus rapide parce
qu'elle Grigny la vice-présidente du
Sénat peut donc enchaîner les votes sur
ses amendements qui ont déjà été
présentés les uns après les autres ont
rejoint tout de suite l'hémicycle à
présent
de 3176 tombent le 4148 de Madame
assassin même avis même vote le 2906
tombe le 4147 même assassin même avis
même vote deux amendements identiques
3499 même penser Monge 4575 madame
assassin
le
4141 de Madame assassin même avis même
vote le 3235 même pensé Monge même avis
même vote le 3170 172 tombes le 3680
madame Poncet Monge même avis même vote
4178 de même assassy le 4150 41502 4156
même assassin même à vie même vote
3674 même pour Simon je mets ma vie même
vote
4154 4177 de même assassin même avis
même vote
3673 même penser mon je me ma vie même
vote
4157 41
64162 de même assassin même à vie même
vote ensuite j'ai les amendements 62
jusqu'à 4235 qui sont
identiques dont le 1125 vient d'être
retiré donc avis défavorable la
Commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ne sont pas adoptées nous
passons à deux amendements devenus
identiques le
452 il y a un scrutin public d'accord
donc le 452 de Madame assassy et le 2116
de la commission avis favorable pour les
deux avis favorables qui est pour qui
contre qui s'abstient sont donc adoptés
le monde en 4158 de Madame assassis
après
quelqu'un demande la parole là non
donc le 4158 donc avec des favorable à
la Commission et du gouvernement donc
qui est pour
qui pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
vous ne suivez pas j'ai l'impression que
ça va pas bien ah c'est le dérouleur
c'est pour ça que je donne à la fois le
nom voilà donc ensuite j'ai le 3175 3489
de Madame ponce même avis même vote
à 3489 a été retiré bon
ensuite j'ai le 4165 41
même avis même vote le 4180 même avis
même vote 4187 et 4188 tons et ensuite
j'ai 4197 4169 4479
et les 4570 et le 4172 tombe
voilà alors maintenant nous passons à
l'amendement 3500 2 madame pensez Monge
et vous l'avez vu lorsque les sénateurs
veulent accélérer ils peuvent le faire
donc après cette le fait que le groupe
écologiste est renoncé à toutes ces
demandes de scrutin public sur cet
article 6 on a donc assisté et bien au
rejet de très nombreux amendements mais
noté toutefois et bien que deux
amendements ont été adoptés celui de la
de d'Élisabeth Doisneau qui est la
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales mais ne restez aussi
et bien un amendement qui a été adopté
de Eliane assassin à la présidente du
groupe communiste d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure et bien Gabriel Attal a dit que
c'était le deuxième amendement de la
gauche auquel il donnait un avis
favorable depuis hier voilà comme quoi
et bien peut-être que les débats ne sont
pas si noir et blanc que ça enfin il
s'agit quand même seulement de deux
amendements voilà les discussions se
poursuivent mais on sent bien que le
rythme s'accélère et que tout le monde
souhaite quand même en arriver à ce
fameux article 7 sur le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite de 62 à 64
ans dans les prochaines minutes ne
quittez pas nous sommes toujours là sur
publictionnelle ou suivant les débats
très attentivement la vie de la
commission sur le 4135 monsieur le
rapporteur
merci Monsieur le Ministre même avis je
mets aux voix donc avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient pas adopter l'amendement
de 1903 de même lubant
merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement est un amendement
rédactionnel qui vise à garantir la
clarté la sincérité des débats par
rapport à notre question des retraites
il existe bien malgré ce que le
gouvernement se plaît à vouloir nous
faire croire une alternative à cette
réforme qui est rejetée par deux
Français sur 3 9 sur 10 parmi les actifs
quand le président de la République on
appelle au bon sens des Français au
moins il devrait les entendre enfin ça a
été dit plusieurs de mes collègues les
milliers de Français sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui et j'ai oublié de préciser
tout à l'heure en évoquant mon
département et la ville de Vire c'est la
première l'ancien conscription de la
première ministre peut-être que elle ne
sera pas insensible à ce qui se passe
dans son territoire
merci beaucoup la vie de la commission
favorable défavorable merci la vie du
gouvernement même avis je mets aux voix
donc l'amendement de 1903 avec un double
avis défavorable qui est pour qui contre
qui s'abstient pas adopté le 4137 a été
défendu la vie de la Commission
merci Monsieur le Ministre ma vie donc
je me vois 4137 avec des favorable qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
pas adopté même pensé pour les 3500
merci la vie de la Commission
merci monsieur le ministre de ma fille
merci donc je mets aux voiles mon 3500
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient l'opté le
4127 donc qui a été défendu la vie de la
Commission
merci
merci je mets aux voix donc cet
amendement qui pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient pas adopté le 4173 qui était
défendu à vide la commission défavorable
avis du gouvernement pareil je mets aux
voix donc qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient pas adopter le 3478
madame ponce
merci la vie de la commission
défavorable merci je mets donc aux voix
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient pas adopté le 3479 madame
ponce
merci la commission
monsieur ministre donc deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté deux
amendements
identiques le 3213 même pensé mange
merci le deuxième a été défendu même
assassin la vie de la Commission sur ces
deux amendements je suppose défavorable
à commission merci Monsieur le Ministre
même avis merci donc je mets au revoir
cet amendement qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés le
3481 madame ponce
merci
mais ma vie monsieur le rapporteur même
la rapporteur défavorable mais voilà je
mets aux voix qui est pour cet
amendement qui est contre qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté le 2905 de même Lubin
défendu avis de la commission
défavorable ce ministre je mets aux voix
qui est pour qui contre qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté
4139 a été défendu la vie de la
commission est défavorable je suppose
monsieur le ministre également donc je
mets aux voix qui est pour qui compte
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopter le 4174
qui a été défendu par Madame assassy La
Villa commission
défavorable monsieur le ministre merci
je mets aux voix qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
trois amendements sur l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 4153 qui a été
défendu le 3238 de même penser Monge
merci le 3487 même pensé manger
également non
s'il vous plaît oui merci même ma
présidente si là j'aimerais prendre le
temps de défendre
la proposition d'un plan qui ouvre
500000 de place de garde adaptée aux
cinq ans parce que je crois entendre
dans cette assemblée qu'on demande
souvent aux femmes de d'avoir plus
d'enfants
et bien je suis désolé mais il y a un
phénomène que bien connu des démographes
qui s'appellent la transition
démographique
c'est la peine de vous dire qu'elle est
irréversible
elle dépend effectivement du niveau
d'éducation des filles des niveaux de la
protection sociale dont la retraite elle
défend aussi du fait que les femmes ou
pas travaillent enfin de beaucoup de
phénomènes et elle est irréversible
et
d'ailleurs je suis un peu étonné parce
qu'en général vous vous
comment vous conseiller la transition
démographique au pays africains mais
quand elle a lieu dans notre beau
continent bien blanc peut-être là il
faudrait qu'elle soit réversible alors
moi ce que je vous propose avec cet
amendement c'est de permettre aux femmes
qui veulent travailler de travailler
plutôt que de leur demander de faire des
enfants et quand elle le souhaite
et du coup de remédier par cet
amendement et bien d'autres
propositions au fait que plusieurs
points séparent le taux d'activité des
femmes parce que elles n'ont pas de
propositions de garde d'enfants etc ou
parce que ne les aurions pas elles ont
un temps partiel subi et donc du coup
ces états temps complexes ça
rapporterait des recettes à notre
protection sociale et je passe quand
même parce qu'on a beaucoup dire on leur
dira demain que l'égalité des
rémunérations entre les femmes et les
hommes apporteraient 6 milliards donc
voilà
des places de crèche plutôt qu'une
injonction aux femmes
d'avoir plus de deux enfants en France
qui est à peu près la moyenne mais
beaucoup la vie de la Commission sur ces
trois amendements
défavorables sur les trois monsieur le
ministre des favorables donc je mets aux
voix
l'amendement 41503 vider favorable
commission et gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui ça tient pas adopté
le 3238 même avis même vote
le 3487 même avis même vote merci trois
amendements dont deux identiques le 3496
monsieur dossu
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement pour rappeler quelques
évidences se rappeler que si les
recettes se sont forcément contractées
c'est d'abord parce que le gouvernement
a exonéré massivement les entreprises
des cotisations sociales le besoin de
financement de la sécurité sociale et de
l'État est ainsi
entretenu par des dispositifs qui
privent la sécurité sociale et les
cotisations et l'état de nombreuses
recettes
les le coût des niches sociales est
évalué à 90 milliards d'euros par la
Cour des comptes soit 3,5 points du
produit intérieur brut certaines
exonérations sont particulièrement
pénalisantes pour le système de retraite
comme les exonérations sur les heures
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas
compensées par l'État leur suppression
rapporterait 2,3 milliards à la branche
vieillesse la suppression d'exonération
de cotisations inutiles rapporterait au
total 10 milliards d'euros en d'autres
termes en faisant travailler deux ans de
plus les Français vous leur faites payer
la facture de vos
errements dogmatiques je remercie
si donc le 4182 4166 ont été défendus
donc la vie de la commission
merci monsieur le ministre des favorable
merci je mets donc aux voix les deux
amendements
identiques 3496 4182 de double avis
défavorable qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient pas d'opté le 4166 même à
vie même vote merci le 32008 même pensé
Monge
même la présidente mon amendement en
faveur des femmes n'ayant pas été votées
je vois que ça nous sert pas à grand
chose de défendre ici nos amendements
pour trouver des solutions pourtant au
problème des recettes de notre régime de
retraite donc
désormais pour le reste de l'article 6
considéré mes amendements comme défendus
alors donc la vie de la commission sur
le 32008 défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre des favorable donc je mets aux
voix cet amendement double avis
défavorable qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté donc le
4184 de même assassin défendue
avis de la commission
monsieur le ministre défavorable je mets
aux voix qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopté le 4185 de
Madame assassy la vie de la commission
défavorable monsieur le ministre des
favorable je mets aux voix qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient je me
demandais un peu de silence quand même
merci trois amendements dont deux
identiques donc le
3498 de Madame poncemonge et le 4191 de
Madame assassy la Commission est
défavorable défavorables je vais mettre
aux voix donc qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstiente pas adopter et le
4192 de madame assassy qui est pour qui
est contre même avis pas adopter même
votre
3183 donc de même penserment je
défavorable défavorables je mets donc
aux voix qui est pour qui est contre pas
adopté le 3211 de même pensé Monge des
favorable défavorables je mets aux voix
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopter le 3200
même voilà nous interrompons quelques
instants la discussion mais vous le
voyez à la discussion et bien les
sénateurs ont mis vraiment le pied sur
l'accélérateur puisque et bien il y a un
total changement de stratégie de la
gauche qui jusqu'ici avait bien
multiplié les prises de parole les
explications de vote sur les différents
amendements et là va très vite les
sénateurs n'expliquent même plus pour la
plupart et bien l'objet de leurs
amendements et les amendements sont
directement mis au vote car on le
comprend et bien l'objectif c'est bien
d'arriver à l'Arctique le 7 indices
quelques dizaines de minutes et là on va
à nouveau changer complètement de rythme
il y avait tout à l'heure 26 prises de
parole mais ça grossissait de minutes en
minutes presque 80 amendements de
suppression Steve il faut dire que
l'article 7 c'est ce que l'on attend
tous le report de l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans oui on sent
comme un peu d'animation dans
l'hémicycle un frisson dans l'hémicycle
tout le monde se prépare évidemment à
examiner cette article 7 et la question
qu'on se pose nous journaliste c'est
bien de savoir si le Sénat entendu le
message de la rue le message de
mobilisations parisiennes et comment ce
message et bien va-t-il se traduire dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat on verra ça dans
quelques instants place en tout cas à
une séquence beaucoup plus plus
politique dans quelques instants donc
avec cet article 7 puisque le
l'hémicycle va être très schématiquement
divisé en deux d'un côté la droite de
l'autre côté et bien la gauche pourquoi
en deux et bien parce que le groupe
macroniste ici le groupe RDP au Sénat ne
compte que 24 sénateurs sur 300 48 tous
les yeux seront donc braqués vers la
droite vers le groupe LR notamment qui
défend l'âge de le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite et évidemment la
gauche la gauche qui sera en quelque
sorte l'animateur de la soirée qui va
nous entraîner jusqu'au bout de la nuit
puisque la gauche est déposée 1300
amendements c'est énorme 1300
amendements et sur ces 1300 amendements
77 amendements sont des amendements de
suppression des amendements qui viennent
dire non au recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite la gauche qui veut donc
montrer qu'elle fait front avec la rue
ici dans cette hémicy contre la réforme
des retraites d'Emmanuel Macron et oui
nous serons là jusqu'au bout de la nuit
un peu tête vers 3 14 du matin merci
beaucoup Steve et on retrouve tout de
suite l'hémicycle ou Pascal Grigny un
service présidente du Sénat continue de
présider la séance
excusez-moi un article additionnel après
l'article 6 mais impensément je le 3226
là nous sommes à défendu merci
mais ma vie même votre
merci le 4000 pardon le 4415 de Madame
assassy même avis même vote
le 4410 de ma massassy même avis même
vote
le
4661 de Madame Vogel même avis même vote
4413 même assassis même avis même vote
alors je vais mettre au voile l'ensemble
de la première partie du projet de loi
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 47 bis tirer un à alinéa 3 du
règlement lorsque le Sénat n'adopte pas
les dispositions de cette partie
l'ensemble du projet de loi est
considéré comme rejeté
y a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote
même vous souhaitez prendre la parole
bien sûr alors madame la Présidente
c'est pas une explication de vote c'est
plutôt de de faire un petit compte-rendu
si je puis dire de cette première partie
qui finalement
pardon
qui arrive en fait dans cette 6e journée
enfin à sa conclusion si je puis dire
puisque nous allons voter cette première
partie je voudrais
nous allons donc un petit peu résumé
les éléments que nous avons pu voter
pendant cette première partie déjà une
une loi qui comprenait à un certain
nombre de sujets dans ces articles entre
l'article liminaire qui définissait
justement cet objectif de loi
paramétrique pour répondre
à la pérennité de notre système de
retraite par répartition et puis ce
premier article dans lequel nous avons
beaucoup parlé des régimes spéciaux
et puis cet article 2 qui nous a
beaucoup occupé parce que nous l'avons
toujours dit ici au Sénat l'importance
de cette loi elle réside dans le fait de
proposer pour les seniors et bien
l'activité qui est nécessaire en tout
cas dans notre société la place des
seniors est importante nous l'avons dit
un ensemble de dispositions ont été
proposées l'index senior je sais que
vous n'étiez pas tous emballés par ce
fameux index mais cependant je pense que
l'on responsabilise et on donne une
certaine transparence sur la politique
des entreprises en termes de maintien et
d'embauche des seniors et puis nous
avons ce fameux CDI qui a été défendu
par mon collègue René Paul Savary avec
beaucoup de brio et auquel nous sommes
vraiment très attachés on reçoit les uns
et les autres quelques petits courriers
nous indiquant combien c'est important
de savoir qu'il ex pas désormais cet
outil parce que même ont été
renvoyés de l'entreprise qu'ils n'ont
pas pu
continuer l'activité professionnelle
dans laquelle ils étaient trop tôt dans
leur dans leur vie et donc nous pensons
qu'il est important de maintenir ce CDI
monsieur le ministre monsieur les
ministres parce que c'est vraiment une
réponse
je dirais à la voix de garage
qu'aujourd'hui on a plutôt tendance à
proposer à nos seniors ensuite nous
avons revu les tableaux d'équilibre
l'objectif d'amortissement de la dette
sociale on y a passé aussi un petit peu
de temps et sur l'annexe A nous avons
depuis ce matin
balayer l'ensemble des sujets que nous
avions déjà évoqué hier avec ces
propositions de cotisations nouvelles
d'imposition nouvelle qui nous était
proposé plutôt par l'ensemble de ces
bancs ici et nous l'avons redit nous ne
voulons pas taxer le travail nous
voulons absolument que les entreprises
puissent justement avoir la même
opportunité de proposer de l'emploi et
que les productions ne soient pas
pénalisées par des cotisations
supplémentaires ni même par des impôts
c'était important de le dire et je pense
que pour les entreprises c'est un signe
aussi favorable pour la compétitivité de
notre monde économique
j'ai dépassé mon temps mais c'est la
première partie madame la Présidente et
je voulais en tout cas vous redire
combien ces débats ont été importants et
que nous allons poursuivre avec le cœur
de cette réforme paramétrique puisque
nous allons désormais parler de l'âge de
report de départ à la retraite et je
pense que nous y sommes aussi
nous sommes en tout cas très impatients
de débattre sur le cœur de cette réforme
merci de votre attention
je vais juste rappeler à mes collègues
que la rapporteur effectivement on
pourrait aussi lui donner un peu moins
de temps mais c'est quand même la
rapporteur pour la Commission et surtout
sur la première partie monsieur manteau
j'ai vous vouliez prendre la parole ah
bon
alors j'étais saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public par la commission des
affaires sociales sur l'ensemble de la
première partie il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
voilà un demande de scrutin public sur
la première partie de ce projet de loi
de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale vous l'avez entendu à
Elisabeth doinot on a résumé les grandes
lignes il s'agit bien de l'extinction
d'un certain nombre de régimes spéciaux
qui demeure avec la clause du grand-père
néanmoins régime spéciaux de la RATP de
la Banque de France des gaziers des
électriciens des clercs de notaire il y
a également et bien dans cette première
partie et bien ce que ce qui avait été
rejeté à l'Assemblée nationale et qui a
été adoptée au Sénat le fameux index
senior index que les Sénat a préféré
limiter aux entreprises qui ont plus de
300 salariés notez que le Sénat il y a
assorti également un CDI senior c'est à
dire un CDI sur lequel et bien les
entreprises n'auraient pas à payer de
cotisations famille voilà et noter
également que lors de cette première
partie les sénateurs ont rajouté et bien
le principe de la réflexion sur
l'introduction d'une part de
capitalisation collective dans notre
système aujourd'hui par répartition
voilà les sénateurs sont encore en train
de voter on écoute le vote
résultat du scrutin votant 344 exprimer
338 pour 236 contre 102 le Sénat a
adopté la première partie de ce texte et
je vais passer la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre
merci madame la Présidente un mot
rapidement pour remercier les sénatrices
et les sénateurs pour remercier leur
rapporteur général le rapporteur ça
varie la présidente de roche vous
remercier chacune et chacun d'entre vous
pour la qualité des débats que nous
avons eu nous avons des désaccords ils
sont nombreux avec certains bancs de
cette hémicycle mais enfin je crois que
nous avons réussi à montrer que nous
étions capables de les exprimer d'une
manière respectueuse républicaine projet
contre projets et c'est évidemment moi
ce qui m'importe la discussion va
maintenant se poursuivre mais je le dis
à l'issue de l'adoption de cette
première partie c'est une étape majeure
dans cette réforme des retraites qui
vient d'être franchie avec le vote de
cette première partie c'est une étape
majeure puisque c'est le vote de la
première partie de ce texte ici au Sénat
une étape majeure aussi puisque
maintenant dans la suite de la
discussion la question est claire
voulez-vous voulons nous équilibrer ou
pas notre système de retraite à horizon
2030 pour permettre de payer les
pensions à bientôt 30 millions de
retraités ou pas si c'est le cas ça
passe par un recul de l'âge légal de
départ puisqu'à l'issue de cette
première partie votre assemblée a refusé
les augmentations d'impôts nombreuses
qui étaient proposées notamment sur les
bancs gauche de cette émission et donc
c'est une étape très importante pour ce
point merci merci alors nous allons
passer à la deuxième partie
alors je suis saisie tout d'abord de
d'un amendement 3680 de Madame ponce sur
les suppressions de l'intitulé
défendu alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
monsieur mise défavorable merci je mets
aux voix donc l'amendement 3680 double
avis défavorable qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
le
3395 madame Poncet Monge sur les deux
prochains
d'accord la vie de la commission
défavorable
monsieur le ministre gouvernement
défavorable je mets aux voix cet
amendement double avis défavorable qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
pas adopté
alors ensuite
deux amendements
alors le premier de Madame poncer Monge
donc il est défendu un bon fond petit
Dossa pour le 2312
oui
allez à quelques secondes de l'article 7
nous sommes avec Gabriel Attal ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous d'abord un mot
sur la tonalité des débats au Sénat vous
venez de remercier les sénateurs est-ce
que vous avez trouvé ça différent de
l'Assemblée oui on a eu de vrais débats
de fond un projet contre projet avec
notamment les bancs de la gauche qui
proposaient des augmentations d'impôts
de cotisations là où effectivement nous
proposons d'équilibrer notre système en
passant par un recul de l'âge légal de
départ ça s'est fait toujours dans un
cadre respectueux républicain c'est ce
que j'ai voulu saluer pas vraiment
d'obstruction alors pour vous de la part
de la gauche il y a eu quelques
longueurs mais on a vu qu'à certains
moments aussi ça accélérait encore une
fois l'important c'est qu'on puisse
parler de tous les sujets alors est-ce
que vous souhaitez quand même du coup
vraiment accélérer sur les débats pour
la suite on le sait il y a des outils à
la main du gouvernement à la main de la
majorité sénatoriale
examiner ce texte les différents sujets
il y a beaucoup de sujets qui arrivent
évidemment le recul de l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans mais il y a aussi des
articles sur l'extension de la retraite
progressive à la fonction publique sur
la question des carrières longues il
faut qu'on puisse examiner tous ces
sujets j'ai pas de doute qu'on
parviendra à le faire alors est-ce que
l'équilibre financier de la réforme va
être assurée Gabriel Attal on a Olivier
du soft qui a dit dans une interview que
300 millions d'euros pourraient manquer
en 2030 et puis on voit un peu la note
qui s'alourdit le coup du CDI Seigneur
qui a été adopté au Sénat le coup de la
surcotte pour les maires de famille
ayant toutes leurs années à 63 ans la
note va s'alourdir ah mais l'équilibre
de notre système de retraite à horizon
2030 c'est un objectif dont nous ne
dérangerons pas mais parce qu'il y a
quoi derrière l'équilibre il y a tout
simplement le fait d'être capable de
continuer à payer les pensions de nos
retraités il y avait 12 millions de
retraités dont il fallait payer la
pension au début des années 2000 on sera
à 20 millions dans quelques années c'est
un doublement sur une génération et donc
la réalité c'est que vous êtes obligé
dans ces conditions de prendre des
mesures pour équilibrer le système sinon
ça veut dire qu'on devrait baisser les
pensions et on le refuse j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que j'étais
défavorable au CDI seniors en tout cas
dans la manière dont il était dont il a
adopté par les sénateurs puisque ça
coûte très cher et je doute de
l'efficacité mais c'est des discussions
qui se poursuivront dans la navette
parlementaire et en commission mixte
paritaire certainement est-ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même des erreurs de
communication dans la façon dont le
gouvernement a géré cette réforme bien
sûr on pense tous au slogan sur les 1200
euros depuis on a compris que c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué que cela et
notamment Isabelle borne a été beaucoup
plus clair et plus complexe ces derniers
jours d'abord une réforme des retraites
c'est toujours difficile moi j'ai pas
d'exemple de réforme des retraites
demandant un effort aux Français qui
était particulièrement populaire quand
vous regardez en arrière c'est toujours
difficile c'est une réforme qui est
assez technique et on peut toujours
considérer qu'on aurait pu faire mieux
mais je pense que l'essentiel c'est en
permanence de chercher à expliquer à
être au contact moi je les fais mais en
termes de communication on peut toujours
évidemment moi je cherche toujours à
être au contact des français via les
médias évidemment mais aussi dans des
réunions publiques que j'ai multiplié
partout en France partout sur le
territoire pour aller au contact des
Français et chercher à expliquer nos
intentions est-ce que vous considérer
que la droite sénatoriale comme votre
allié sur ce texte et au-delà désormais
mais vous savez en fait moi j'ai jamais
demandé à la droite sénatoriale ou LR de
l'assemblée de se rallier à nos
convictions tout simplement d'être mais
tout simplement d'être fidèle au leur en
votant pour ce texte ils sont fidèles à
leurs conditions et à ce qu'ils ont
toujours porté en tout cas depuis des
années ici au Sénat merci merci beaucoup
Gabriel d'avoir répondu à mes questions
on va tout de suite rejoindre l'émission
là l'article 7 doit être en train de
commencer tout de suite on rejoint les
mystiques de l'article 7 cette notion
porte le numéro 4750 et la parole est à
Madame A poursu poli pour la motion et
pour deux minutes
comme vous voulez ma chère collègues
vous avez deux minutes
merci madame la Présidente nous y sommes
au coeur de votre projet de loi déclaré
irrecevable par notre peuple la
mobilisation est massive la levée
populaire rappelle les grandes heures de
l'histoire sociale de notre pays
monsieur le ministre il vous reste la
légalité institutionnelle mais vous avez
perdu la légitimité sociale nous ne
pourrons plus poursuivre le débat de la
même manière qu'hier votre texte est
massivement rejeté nous le savions tous
depuis le 19 janvier date de la première
journée de manifestation et de grève nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens n'ont pas
lâché ils sont aujourd'hui plus nombreux
encore dans l'action c'est un
raz-de-marée contre la réforme
profondément injuste de Monsieur Macron
et de son gouvernement nous l'avons dit
répéter comment avez-vous osé provoquer
le pays ainsi s'il y a blocage si nous
sommes dans cette situation de crise
sociale majeure monsieur le ministre aux
côtés
centrale du président de la République
et de la première ministre vous emportez
l'unique responsabilité votre obsession
libérale votre pensée dogmatique vous
ont poussé à la faute vous êtes tombé
dans votre propre piège dont vous aurez
bien du mal à vous sortir vous n'avez
plus expliqué au travailleur qu'il soit
salarié ou non pourquoi ils devront
s'user à la tâche plus longtemps porter
l'âge légal du départ à la retraite à 64
ans n'a pu passer car tous ont bien
compris que d'autres moyens existent
pour financer le régime des retraites
par répartition d'autres solutions dont
vous n'avez pas parlé à commencer par
mettre à contribution les richesses
considérables de la grande puissance que
nous sommes main dans la main le
président de la République et la
majorité sénatoriale dans l'affichage
enfin de cette union des droites veulent
imposer la destruction d'un pilier de
notre République la sécurité sociale
écoutons le peuple écoutons pour une
fois le peuple soutenez mes chers
collègues notre demande refuser l'âge de
départ à 64 ans merci chers collègue
alors quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
écoutez merci madame la Présidente mais
c'est strictement interdit jour appelle
mes collègues un peu de respect quand
même pour l'assistance s'il vous plaît
vous voulez peut-être toujours fait moi
je vous dis c'est interdit madame la
Présidente assassy j'en suis désolée
voilà la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur ne vous n'avez pas la parole
même la présidente
non même la Présidente je lui ai donné
la parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
je suis en cours de parole c'est bien
parce que c'est le rapporteur merci
Madame Liliane bon effet tribune étant
passé on va revenir à la sérénité des
débats
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes sereins nous aussi parce que
nous pensons que véritablement si nous
proposons une réforme dont on sait
qu'elle peut être difficile à accepter
pour certains
c'est pour faire que nous puissions
maintenir notre système de répartition à
l'équilibre et quand on sait que nous
avons de moins en moins de cotisants et
des retraites qui durent de plus en plus
longtemps si nous ne prenons pas nos
responsabilités ce sont les générations
futures qui paieront la note et qui la
paieront beaucoup plus cher il nous
appartient et vous le savez
de poursuivre le débat nos concitoyens
l'attendent ce débat en ce qui concerne
effectivement ces inégalités ces
inégalités qu'il y a dans la vie
professionnelle ces inégalités qui se
déclinent également dans le système de
retraite et nos concitoyens sont
impatients
propose que leur propose
qu'on leur propose des mesures qui
prennent en compte ces inégalités
qui prennent en compte l'usure
professionnelle qui prennent en compte
les mers de famille ça fait déjà
plus de trois jours que nous siègeons où
nous avons entendu nombre de discours
tout à fait justifié et il nous
appartient maintenant de passer à l'acte
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
donnons un avis défavorable pour
retourner en commission faire le travail
que nous avons déjà largement fait merci
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
la discussion sur la première partie a
montré que le sujet s'il est complexe
est aussi un sujet qui peut être clivant
et qui a l'occasion de cette discussion
première partie sur les différents
articles financiers sur les déclarations
générales ces questions relatives à
l'âge au choix que nous avons fait
évidemment et il faut le dire des
demander un effort aux Français avec un
peu plus de travail faire
progressivement certes certes de manière
plus aussi adaptée possible et aussi
justement réparti que possible peut
faire débat ce que ce cheval que nous
avons fait nous l'avons fait pour deux
raisons parce que c'est celui qui permet
d'une part de ramener le système à
l'équilibre et d'autre part de financer
à la fois les mesures d'accompagnement
et les droits nouveaux que nous créons
avec cette réforme je crois que les
travaux en commission les travaux à
l'occasion de la première partie ont
déjà largement éclairé le débat qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de
retarder ce débat sur l'article 7 donc
la vie est défavorable
merci beaucoup alors y a-t-il des
explications de vote un représentant par
groupe même
merci madame la Présidente cet article
est effectivement au coeur de la réforme
la mobilisation considérable à laquelle
nous assistons aujourd'hui la grève
puissante qui a été lancée dans le
secteur public comme dans le secteur
privé à un objectif clair et précis le
retrait de ce projet détestable qui
institut le recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite mais aussi de tout
l'habillage l'accompagnant relevant bien
souvent de la manipulation même du
mensonge comme ce plancher à 2000 à 1200
euros pardon destiné d'abord à
l'ensemble des retraités à venir et
actuels pour finalement être réservé à
10000 au mieux 20 000 personnes cette
mobilisation marque aussi un ras-le-bol
bien plus profond une colère rentrée
cette colère elle s'exprime comme contre
cette société injuste marquée par la
précarité précarité dans le travail le
logement l'accès aux soins le
déroulement des études l'accès aux
services publics nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens ne peuvent plus de toutes
ces inégalités qui s'accroisent dans
notre pays avec un étalage indécent de
richesse un affichage de profits
dantesques accumulés y compris sur le
dos des crises sanitaires énergie
énergétique sur la sur la guerre c'est
profiteurs de crise les maîtres de la
finance ceux qui tiennent l'actionnariat
ont poussé à une telle réforme ce sont
eux qui ont tenu la main de Monsieur
Macron pour écrire ce nouvel
asservissement que décrète ce projet de
loi les femmes et les hommes de ce pays
le voient le savent elle est le cri ils
ont soif de justice d'égalité la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat comme le Parlement tout entier
doit travailler dans la précipitation
extrême décidée par le seul gouvernement
la voix choisie de l'article 47 1 permet
d'aller vite mais ça n'est pas
démocratique ce n'est pas le bon vecteur
législatif il est temps maintenant
madame la Présidente de nous réunir à
nouveau pour prendre en compte ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui une très grande
colère et un rejet massif de cette
réforme scélérate mais si même la
présidente rossignol
merci Madame la pardon merci madame la
Présidente il y a un instant le
rapporteur nous disait ça fait trois
jours que nous sions nous pouvons donc
continuer il n'y a pas de raison de
retourner en commission ça fait trois
jours que nous sions et que nous parlons
de gens qui travaillent depuis plus de
40 ans qui eux attendent la retraite qui
prennent le train tous les matins c'est
se demander partement pour beaucoup
d'entre eux qui tous les jours compte
parce que vous n'y pensez pas vous n'y
pensez pas aux gens qui ont un
calendrier et qui cochent les jours
parce que après une vie de travail après
une vie de souffrance après une vie de
fatigue ils attendent la retraite parce
que c'est le moment ils pourront enfin
s'occuper de leur petit enfant
avoir des loisirs et puis surtout se
reposer alors franchement entre des gens
qui travaillent depuis plus de 40 ans et
qu'attendent la retraite et nous qui
travaillons depuis trois jours retourner
en commission on a le temps on peut le
faire et puis et par ailleurs
retourner en commission pourquoi faire
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser en
bon membre de la commission des affaires
sociales que nous sommes les uns et les
autres mais je vous proposais déjà un
ordre du jour pour le retour en
commission recevoir l'Inter syndicale
nous ne l'avons jamais fait en
commission en tant que tel
et puis peut-être que ça donnera des
idées au gouvernement et au ministre et
à la première ministre qui pourront eux
aussi pendant que nous serons en
commission à rediscuter de cet article 7
recevoir l'intersydical ils ne le sont
jamais reçues
alors je vous suggère effectivement de
faire comme mon groupe de voter cette
motion en commission pour examiner
article 7
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Gontard
oui merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente de la même manière évidemment
que tout ce qui est soutiendrons ce
renvoi en commission d'abord quand même
une remarque parce que c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'on met des visages
derrière cette réforme à chaque fois
qu'on parle des gens à chaque fois qu'on
met des prénoms à chaque fois qu'on cite
des professions ça vous gêne on entend
et je pense que c'est particulièrement
oui mais ça pose quand même question
parce que c'est quand même ce qu'on est
en train de faire on est en train de
changer de la vie de gens justement
derrière leur prénom derrière le métier
et de leur dire que vous allez
travailler un an deux ans de plus c'est
une réalité et un moment va falloir
aussi l'assumer parce que c'est pas que
des chiffres c'est pas que des textes
derrière il y a des personnes donc ça je
pense que c'est aussi important que vous
l'ayez en tête ensuite se renvoie en
commission et le fait peut-être d'avoir
un peu plus de temps pour que
effectivement je vois que le ministre
ont besoin de discuter ont besoin de
parler donc je pense qu'on a peut-être
besoin de se renvoi en commission merci
Monsieur le merci monsieur le ministre
et puis
également j'ai lu j'ai entendu à peu
près j'ai vu dans certains articles en
tout cas il y a des bruits qui courent
qui auraient des réunions en tout cas
qu'on commencerait à discuter de la
future de la future CMP qu'on sera en
train de se mettre d'accord parce que
d'ailleurs monsieur le rapporteur n'est
plus le rapporteur de la commission
parce que il dit nous il est le
rapporteur du groupe du groupe LR il est
le rapporteur de ce texte et le
rapporteur du gouvernement donc très
bien je veux dire vous êtes en train de
faire un texte entre vous c'est très
bien donc je pense qu'il y a peut-être
ce temps là mais nous on a peut-être
aussi du temps pour avancer pour vous
faire des propositions on a essayé d'en
faire depuis trois jours je pense qu'on
va encore en faire et on a encore du
temps devant nous et on va pas se priver
de vous faire des propositions parce que
effectivement ce texte est
particulièrement injuste et je pense que
les manifestations ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui sans précédent dans notre
pays un moment il va falloir peut-être
l'entendre parce que non on ne gouverne
pas contre le peuple
merci Monsieur mouillé
merci madame le Président mes chers
collègues nous comprenons tout à fait
que nous sommes là à la veille quelques
minutes de l'examen de l'article 7 et
que vu la situation de la journée vous
suit motivé remonté pour porter vos
valeurs et donc votre vision on le
comprend tout à fait mais toutefois
comme ça a été très bien dit par le
rapporteur rappelons que nous sommes
cohérents dans nos démarches et que le
début de l'examen de ce texte nous
savons que la techno 7 et l'article
fondamentale pour équilibrer notre futur
système de retraite à l'aube de 2030
c'était essentiel nous le savons et vous
vous devez évoquer souvent des visages
des rencontres des personnes souffrantes
que vous rencontrez mais nous également
lorsqu'on rencontre un certain nombre de
couples et que on évoque avec eux
l'avenir de leur retraite souvent nous
disent on n'aura pas de retraite les
plus jeunes j'ai dit on n'aura pas de
retraite non pas parce que vous évoquez
vos arguments c'est parce qu'ils savent
pertinemment que si on met pas en place
une réforme courageuse avec des vraies
valeurs nous serons incapables de
financer un niveau digne de retraite et
donc c'est l'outil que nous proposons
aujourd'hui autour démarche là donc on a
aussi ce regard vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens et puis pour ceux qui
évoquent le fait de d'avoir plus de
temps en commission l'interse à
desquelles a été reçu au commission il
fallait peut-être présent que les choses
à ce moment-là et puis depuis 4 ans nous
avons le même discours nous travaillons
nous avons reçu un sapondre d'acteurs
dans cette mission donc il y a rien de
nouveau nous sommes nous sommes prêts
les années rencontrés ont été vus
simplement un moment donné relisez les
contrôles de commission et on gagne du
temps ce soir merci
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais donner la parole à madame
la Présidente de la Commission
merci madame la Présidente oui j'avais
pris la parole pour rappeler en effet
que le 15 février nous avons passé la
matinée à recevoir les organisations
syndicales les organisations patronales
et que les rapports
je ne sais pas si vous êtes intervenus
lors de cette commission madame madame
Rossignol on regardera
je n'en ai pas vraiment le souvenir mais
pourquoi pas oui pourquoi pas mais enfin
ça c'est un détail les rapporteurs
depuis
des années que nous faisons des
amendements pvss reçoivent les
organisations syndicales certes ils ne
sont pas d'accord avec la proposition
qu'on fait mais néanmoins nous les
recevons et puis moi je vais vous dire
j'en ai un peu marre de ces propos ici
disons mais qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez du travail qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez de la vie qu'est-ce que vous
savez vous de nos origines qu'est-ce que
vous savez nous nos vies
rien
bonne journée un petit peu marre
qu'est-ce que vous savez de nos vies
qu'est-ce que vous savez de nos familles
qu'est-ce que vous savez ce qu'on a vécu
ou ce que nos parents ont vécu rien
alors vous arrêtez avec ça
merci
alors je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
motion de renvoi à la commission de 7 la
vie du gouvernement et de la commission
sont défavorables qui est pour
cette motion qui est contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopté
alors à l'article 7 j'ai des demandes de
prise de parole et le premier monsieur
le rapporteur Savary
non c'est pas possible oui merci madame
la Présidente nous y voilà nous y voilà
c'est le Ministre ça fait quatre ans
qu'on vous propose ce type
d'acheitecture de réforme c'est pas
parce que nous sommes des tétus c'est
parce que nous pensons que c'est le
meilleur moyen de faire en sorte de
pouvoir équilibrer notre système de
retraite si nous voulons le confier à
nos enfants et effectivement on sait que
nous avons un système fondé sur deux
piliers à la fois la durée de cotisation
et un autre pilier un âge légal la durée
de cotisation qui a été ramenée de 41
ans et demi à 43 ans
par un gouvernement que vous avez
largement soutenu et on vous en remercie
parce que c'est tout à fait important
mais on sait que cette durée de
cotisation quand on augmente elle
concerne davantage ceux qui commencent
tôt mais elle a un défaut c'est que le
niveau de pension moyenne va diminuer
derrière
c'est l'équation qui est ainsi faite
dans le calcul des pensions de carrière
et puis il y a un deuxième vecteur c'est
l'âge légal on sait que l'âge légal
touche plus spécifiquement et fait pour
ça pour faire en sorte que l'on puisse
protéger ceux qui commencent à
travailler état et il a l'avantage c'est
d'augmenter le niveau des pensions et
nous avons pensé déjà depuis quatre ans
qu'il était important de trouver un
équilibre entre les deux de façon à ce
que quand on demande un effort collectif
à l'ensemble des Français il y ait le
moins d'inégalité possible c'est la
raison pour laquelle ces inégalités nous
souhaitons les gommer
parce que elles sont réelles et en
conséquence monsieur le ministre si vous
nous avez rejoint dans la démarche
vous n'avez pas été tout à fait jusqu'au
bout il reste encore un bout de chemin à
faire parce que si nous avions présenté
nous cette réforme nous l'aurions pas
fait de cette façon nous aurions déjà
consulté
nous aurions déjà consulter les sociaux
avant et nous aurions pris en compte les
difficultés rencontrées dans le cadre de
cet effort collectif c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous allons débattre et
que je ne suis pas sûr que 57
amendements de suppression tout se
identique face correctement avancer le
débat merci
monsieur le rapporteur alors pour les
prises de parole madame la Présidente
Eliane assassy oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lors de la présentation du projet de loi
la première ministre a placé son projet
sous le signe de je cite la préservation
d'un système menacé menacé par
l'accumulation des déficits qui seraient
irresponsable ce sont ces mots le
gouvernement justifie l'allongement de
l'âge légal à 64 ans et de la durée de
cotisation à 43 annuités par le déficit
de système de retraite pour 2030 à 13,5
milliard d'euros je rappelle quand même
qu'en 2019 lors de la précédente réforme
le gouvernement invoquait déjà
l'impérius nécessité de réformer le
système de retraite face au risque d'un
déficit du régime de 10 milliards
d'euros en 2022 la réforme fut
abandonnée sans réforme le système de
retraite a été excédentaire de 3,7
milliards d'euros alors on peut
s'interroger sur votre entêtement
monsieur le ministre de bien de vouloir
imposer deux années de travail
supplémentaire à nos concitoyens et si
je ne connais pas la vie de chaque
parlementaire ici présent je connais
celle de centaines de s'écano Dionysiens
parmi lesquels celles et ceux que nous
avons applaudis pendant l'épidé
l'épidémie et qui refuse aujourd'hui
qu'on leur vole deux années de leur vie
les 8 syndicats de salariés sont unis
dans l'intercyndical
ils ont organisé cinq journées de
mobilisation qui ont rassemblé
énormément de monde je rappelle que le
19 janvier il y avait manifeste en le 31
janvier 2,8 le 7 2 millions le 11 2,5
millions le 16 1,3 millions et c'était
pendant les vacances scolaires
aujourd'hui et nous y est on présente je
me félicite d'un mouvement social
d'ampleur et rassembleur ce sont plus de
3,5 millions de manifestants parmi
lesquels des milliers de jeunes qui ont
défilé aujourd'hui autour d'un mot
d'ordre retrait de votre réforme
monsieur le ministre votre obstination
met en danger notre société et vous vous
obstinez avec la complicité de la
majorité sénatoriale alors je vous le
dis sincèrement retirer ce projet de loi
pendant qu'il est encore temps mais si
même Cathy a pour ce poli
merci madame la
Présidente excusez-moi Xavier Bertrand
demandait je cite à la fin de cette
décennie il faudra que l'on arrive à
deux années de travail en plus en
excluant ceux qui ont son usé par le
boulot pour Valérie Pécresse je cite
reculer à 65 ans avec des contreparties
pour les longs les carrières longues et
sur la pénibilité Michel Barnier
défendait quant à lui une pension
minimale à 1000 euros philippe Juvin
était le seul candidat qui demandait la
mise en oeuvre d'une capitalisation
collective complémentaire en décembre
2022 pour l'élection du président du
parti des républicains notre collègue
s'est amateur le candidat Bruno
Retailleau défendait la fermeture des
régimes spéciaux l'allongement à 64 ans
et 43 annuités comme le gouvernement
tandis que le député Aurélien Pradier
s'opposé à l'âge à l'allongement de
l'âge légal le candidat élu depuis
président des républicains érectionti
défendait lui le report en 2027 l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 65 ans
et à 63 ans pour les carrières longues
cette réforme des retraites ne
correspond donc ni au projet d'Aurélien
Pradier ni d'érections ni de Xavier
Bertrand ni de Philippe Juvin mais
uniquement à celle portée par le
président du groupe les républicains
monsieur retaillod
alors alors chers collègues en attendant
que vous vous mettez d'accord évidemment
pas ici parce qu'ici c'est quand même un
pour tous pour un et bien je vous
propose de retirer votre projet de
retraite néfaste pour les Français et
les Françaises je vous remercie merci
même Laurence Cohen vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente le
gouvernement justifie le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite comme une
réforme de justice et de progrès ce même
gouvernement se félicite d'acter l'âge
de 64 ans au lieu de 65 ans comme s'il
travaillait deux années de plus ne
représentait rien non seulement la
potion est amère mais elle est indigeste
monsieur le ministre les femmes vont
souffrir de cette réforme et le report
de l'âge légal défendu par ce présent
article aura de lourdes sur elle et leur
quotidien même si c'est l'ensemble des
Français qui vont souffrir les femmes
subissent déjà de nombreuses inégalités
lors de la recherche d'emploi sur les
salaires sur les conséquences des crises
sur leur représentation dans les métiers
pénibles et non valorisés la réforme ne
réduira pas ses inégalités au contraire
elle les creusera à chaque fois qu'on
repousse la durée de cotisation on la
rend toujours moins atteignable pour les
femmes si les salaires des femmes sont
inférieurs en moyenne de 22% de ceux des
hommes leurs pensions de droit est
inférieur de 40% à celle des hommes
alors s'il vous plaît monsieur le
ministre assumez vos positions arrêtez
ces mensonges qui laissent sous-entendre
que cette réforme est favorable aux
femmes elle subissent depuis des
décennies des réformes injustes et cette
réforme ajoute une pièce à la machine et
confirme le modèle de société
antisociale que vous défendez si vous
voulez renflouer les caisses faites
respecter la loi en matière d'égalité
salariale on voulait déjà on vous l'a
déjà dit 6 milliards supplémentaires de
cotisations sociales non seulement cette
égalité dans la vie active permettrait
mécaniquement d'augmenter le niveau de
pension des femmes mais en plus cela
permettrait de revaloriser de façon bien
plus importante que ce que vous faites
les prestations sociales et les
retraites alors ne cherchez pas de faux
arguments de faux prétextes pour
justifier cette réforme retirer là
écoutez la voix de la rue
merci la parole est à Monsieur Thierry
Cosic
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'un de nos illustre prédécesseur le
président Mitterrand nous avait prévenu
après moi
il n'y aura que des comptables
à l'examen de cet article monsieur le
ministre comment lui donner tort cet
article 7 vient toucher au cœur le
projet que vous portez et il ne trahit
que trop bien l'idéologie qui vous anime
en la matière
tout d'abord permettez-moi de vous dire
que cet article me paraît quasi
anachronique tant il fait fi des
bouleversements qui traversent notre
société depuis quelques années et auquel
le gouvernement semble faire mais
pourtant la forte mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui en témoigne nous vivons
une période de changement sociétaux
gigantesque avec un nouveau rapport au
travail qui est en mutation une
déstabilisation liée à la crise
sanitaire qui laisse encore des traces
aujourd'hui
l'ignorer c'est aller dans le mur
pour schématiser il y a trois grands
paramètres sur lesquels jouer pour
réformer notre système de retraite l'âge
de départ la durée et le niveau de
cotisation
des trois il n'y en a qu'un seul qui
touche les salariés de manière inégale
si la mesure d'âge car vous le savez
elle ne prend pas en considération la
date d'entrée sur le marché du travail
de fait en repoussant comme vous le
faites là je les gale vous envoyez une
facture
différente à nos concitoyens selon le
moment auquel ils auront commencé à
travailler et une fois n'est pas coutume
la facture la plus lourde elle est pour
ceux qu'on a appelé les travailleurs de
la deuxième ligne pendant la pandémie
les hôtes et hôtesses de caisses les
éboueurs les agents d'entretien ou les
aides à domicile qui sont aussi les
grands perdants de la mondialisation et
de la numérisation de l'économie voilà
comment vous remercier Monsieur le
Ministre toute cette frange de salariés
dont on a mesuré l'importance pendant la
crise sanitaire et qui ont commencé à
travailler jeunes et on les mettait les
plus les plus pénibles merci
madame Marie Arlette Carlotti
vous le voyez sur cet article 7 les
sénateurs de la gauche multiplient les
prises de parole 26 prises de parole qui
sont prévus avant et bien d'examiner le
cœur de la réforme c'est à dire cet
article qui prévoit le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite de 62 à 64
ans c'est maintenant marie-arlet
Carlotti un sénatrice socialiste qui
s'exprime
le pas parce qu'elle est injuste à
travers le report de l'âge de départ à
64 ans vous faites supporter la totalité
des efforts sur les seuls travailleurs
les classes moyennes les plus
vulnérables ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt qui ont exercé des
métiers difficiles ceux qui ont du mal à
se maintenir en emploi après 58 ans les
femmes les personnes précaires au
chômage en maladie au RSA alors
qu'aucune aucune contribution n'est
demandée aux employeurs aux revenus aux
actionnaires non monsieur le ministre
votre réforme n'est pas de gauche elle
va à l'encontre de nos valeurs de notre
récit collectif souveniez en vous
souvenez-vous de ça vous avez présenté
un bilan comptable alors que nous ici
nous vous parlons d'un projet de société
et jusqu'ici au débats ont été des
dialogues de sourds sauf que depuis
aujourd'hui les rapports de force sont
claire la colère des Français vous
oblige elle vous oblige à prendre une
ultime décision soit vous renoncez à
fracturer le pays à mettre les Français
dans la rue vous retirez votre réforme
ouvrez des négociations
avec les partenaires sociaux soit vous
vous obstinez à vouloir passer en force
et je crains qu'à ce moment là vous
devriez avoir au pire désormais le
président de la République ne peut plus
se défiler il faut qu'il parle aux
Français qui ne les poussent plus à bout
qu'il ne les respecte et qu'en frais
enfin vous et lui vous preniez acte du
rejet de cette réforme
merci la parole est à monsieur le
Président Pierre Laurent
la question qui nous occupe à cette
heure est une question
démocratique majeure après l'échec de
cette réforme à l'Assemblée nationale
une majorité du Sénat va-t-elle décider
de permettre le coup de force qui a été
qui est tenté par le gouvernement contre
les deux plus belles années de rotin des
Français un coup de force contre
l'immense majorité du pays un coup de
force contre tous les syndicats un coup
de force contre l'avenir du régime de
retraite par répartition nous débattons
ici depuis le 2 mars ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par Madame la rapporteur depuis
6 jours les Français nous écoutent les
Français nous suivent ils ont entendu
tous les arguments les vôtres les nôtres
ceux du rapporteur ceux du gouvernement
ils ont manifesté aujourd'hui en
connaissance de cause
et le pays a répondu clairement que pour
lui c'était non et il a dit non dans
toutes les villes de France dans tous
les départements dans toute nos régions
tous nos électeurs étaient dans la rue
quand je dis tous nos électeurs c'est
les nôtres c'est les vôtres aussi tout
c'était dans la rue pour dire NON de
toute catégories sociales et j'attire
votre attention parce que c'est un fait
majeur de la journée d'aujourd'hui
l'entrée en lice massif de la jeunesse
de la jeunesse dans les manifestations
et cela va s'amplifier
nous avons vérifié pendant cette
discussion ce que les syndicats ont
vérifié pendant trois mois en essayant
de négocier avec le gouvernement le
gouvernement et la droite ne veulent
rien négocier vous êtes obsédé par une
seule idée les 64 ans à part ça rien ne
vous intéresse aucune piste alternative
ne trouve grâce à vos yeux et bien je le
répète face au pays qui est unanimement
mobilisé c'est un coup de force ne
donnez pas la main à ce coup de force
sénateur et sénatrice du Sénat nous
n'avons pas à le faire
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
une minorité peut pas bloquer le pays
aujourd'hui vous êtes seul plus personne
ne croit en votre projet mise à part
peut-être encore la droite sénatoriale
dont je tiens à les féliciter pour leur
talent même sans parler vous avez réussi
à empirer le texte avec le contrat
dernier embauche ou en introduisant une
part de capitalisation aujourd'hui
massivement les travailleurs et
travailleuses vous ont répondu ils ont
déferlé dans toutes les rues à Paris
comme en province dans toutes les
sous-préfectures et les villages pour
vous dire non non ils ne veulent pas
qu'on leur vole les deux plus belles
années de leur vie à la retraite c'est
le Ministre arrêté cette guerre sociale
aux travailleurs et travailleurs
essentiels et utiles aux salariés du
privé comme du public au premier
deuxième et troisième ligne au commerce
artisan professionnel
et chef d'entreprise aux jeunes et
retraités tout le monde est uni pour
vous dire STOP il n'y a qu'une seule
option maintenant qui est sur la table
c'est celle du retrait de votre projet
de loi personne ne veut cela et en plus
tous vos arguments sont tombés un par un
parce que nous vous avons fait pendant 5
jours beaucoup de propositions
alternatives des propositions de
financement taxer le capital faire
l'égalité salariale mettre un million de
personnes en emploi ce sont des
ressources supplémentaires et vous les
refusez parce que vous n'avez comme la
dit Pierre Laurent qu'une seule
obsession faire payer au million de
travailleurs et travailleuses la crise
est donc les faire travailler chacune et
chacun deux ans pour tous et donc nous
nous continuerons à pied à pied
déterminé utile pour faire échec à ce
projet jusqu'au retrait
merci la parole est à Monsieur voilà les
sénateurs continuent à multiplier les
prises de parole sur cet article 7 sur
le report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis merci beaucoup à Steve
Jourdain de nous avoir accompagné tout
au long de cette émission vous allez
pouvoir suivre la suite des débats à
partir de 22h sur Public Sénat avec
Mathias Arès et Quentin Calmet qui sera
à ma place donc à 22h ne manquez pas la
suite des débats sur l'article 7 vous
aurez encore c'est un nombre de prises
de parole vous aurez aussi et bien les
amendements de suppression et puis
toutes les discussions qui s'annoncent
passionnantes autour de cet article
névralgique de cette réforme des
retraites l'article 7 qui porte donc sur
le report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ne manquez pas non
plus toutes nos explications sur notre
site public sénat.fr très bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]